foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hello
hello hello hello
you're so beautiful
[Music]
foreign
till we get bored like a feather
s
[Music]
[Applause]
we're floating out
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
tell me what you think about this place
here with dreams are made of
[Music]
what you think about the weather we can
do the small talk till we get bored like
a feather we're floating
we're floating we're floating down
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I think
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
I don't know
[Music]
okay
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello everybody uh who's watching this
and confused at what it is I'm here to
explain it my name is Ludwig welcome to
chess clash which is a partnership
between chess.com and Clash of Clans and
luckily for me I have two people who
know what I'm talking about here all
right let's welcome in our my co-host on
my left here Danny of chess.com you're
used to wearing a chess suit I I sure am
what what is this true you're rocking
here no I wanted to make sure that
nobody in the streets mistook me for a
dumb American yeah making a French joke
and obviously someone who played chess
and I accomplished that today as I
walked around Paris you do give dumb
American Vibes a little bit but they
don't know how good you are at chess If
Only They knew if only they do what a
shirt to do it and then on my right I
have Eric our expert today at Clash of
Clans in all things Clash is that fair
to say mostly yeah for Clash of Clans
definitely but it's gonna be it's gonna
be a wild ride with the Clash Royale so
uh we'll see what the players got for us
and then for everyone at home what what
dude what is it why are you live right
now well I'm here to I'm here to show
this all right we talked about this
during POG Champs five there's a
partnership between chess and The Clash
two games you might have played on the
toilet at one point in your life and
today they have brought them together in
a beautiful way and to show that off we
have some rules to go over right some
some format things so I believe we can
pull up a little bit of the rules right
now the chess Royale 1v1 uh there's a
few different formats we're gonna play
today six different challenges uh and
all the challenges are going to work in
different ways we'll go over them as
they come uh but the big thing you have
to keep in mind is we're focused on two
teams team King and team Barbarian and
each team is composed of four Duos eight
people each Duo is composed of a chess
person and a clash person and we'll go
over whether that chessperson's dog
water or worth being here and same with
the Clash people uh and but will be very
nice everybody because you know
I'm professional all right oh my God
that I feel like the monkey and toys we
just entered a new one what is this all
right oh my God this is terrifying look
at this
I saw in all caps in the Discord it said
go full cam now and I'm seeing everyone
who didn't do it right here well anyway
this is the uh these are the people
playing behind me you can see the Duos
right now so let's let's waste no
further time let's start introducing our
Duos our teams starting with Team King
our first Duo of the day is I would
argue one of the most polarizing
uh we have OJ and virtual on team King
over here this is all of Team King you
can see but OJ and virtual are our first
Duo now I say it's polarizing because
Eric you're saying OJ kind of a goat
yeah I mean he's the biggest Clash
Royale YouTuber in the world uh I I
assume that means he's pretty good at it
I don't know what he can do in Clash of
Clans but I mean he's in a rocket in
Clash Royale I know that biggest in the
world and then we're joined as the chess
representative virtual yeah Danny how do
you feel that this is your chess
representative what's virtual's relative
skill rating for for Eric and anyone at
home I think that I think worship would
be upset if I didn't just call attention
to the fact that he is by far the
biggest Underdog I'm using the
appropriate word okay
he did win the POG Champs consolation
sure right yeah it was at your place but
also
um competing against the likes of Gotham
chess and I'm on Hamilton worshipable
has his work cut out for him in order to
maintain that that dub in front of his
name I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna say I'm
excited to see this because I have no
idea who OJ is but he's great at Clash
Royale because he he's gonna need to be
great if they're gonna win this thing
yeah I would say he is to class or
excuse me he is to chess what I am to
smash
mostly there for a good time anyway
let's go to our next duo we got a few to
get through here so we'll go a little
quicker Duo number two and this one's
kind of fearsome because the Clash
player has a decent amount of Chess
experience as well it's sapnap in Gotham
chest and so sapnap's actually The Clash
person here which I totally believe
sapnap will delve into any game I don't
know if you have any experience with
staff Napper knowledge uh he's a he's a
Minecraft he's a Minecraft guy right
he's like like before he's just a gamer
he likes all games and he's played a lot
of clash in his day and then Gotham
chess one of the strongest chess players
here International Master uh that's a
strong Duo this has got to be one of the
teams to beat I think sapnap you could
argue is as good as virtual not a chess
I think I think everybody should be
equally bad at Clash so like I think
they just need to win on the chest side
right okay we'll see yeah but this is
definitely a strong team agreed and
let's go to our next Duo now these Duos
by the way are all under the team King
so they're not competing against each
other they'll be competing against team
Barbarian will go over them in a second
but first we have Christine Christine
Christine Christine Christina Christina
uh and maestro luison luison
I'm saying it French yeah we say Spanish
Luis luisan Louis Home Maisha Louis son
so Christina Nina as I said a lot of
nineties there but she's played pop
Champs and uh louisan is probably one of
the most well-known Spanish
speaking chess commentators and
Personalities in the world this would be
a fun one
perfect look excited to see them and we
have our fourth and final Duo of the
team King
is that zocus
jokus
you know don't know how to say that
that's fair that's fair there's an X in
there I don't know there's an X in there
no they're like the commentators you're
really bring in the knowledge I love
that you know that I don't know because
we're we're not bringing knowledge right
and we're bringing vibes okay and and
when we mess up everybody's name they're
not gonna they're not gonna yell at us
on twitter.com because they respect our
Vibes too much zocused and Rey Enigma
who I saw in a YouTube video play
Kasparov and lose and I said who is it
yeah and I just thought that they were
Gotham chess in a mass but it turns out
we have confirmed today impossible
it at one point just so you know I was
accused of being this guy Ray Enigma
yeah we've been we're confirming here
I'm clearly but a lot of people have
been accused of being Rey Enigma people
accuse me yeah I mean the relative chess
skill they couldn't stop by the size of
my traps compared to Ray enigmas but you
know that's another conversation that's
our team King let's get over to team
Barbarian see the people that are up
against today because it's eight equally
skilled Gamers and chess players
starting off with sir tag and Amon
Hamilton sir tag
how's he sir tag is very very good at
Clash so I think when he's paired with
him on that's actually going to be a
very very good team okay here's the
thing about him on Hamilton best chess
player here yeah and actually the only
Grand Master over to win a chess boxing
match I don't know if you know anything
about Chess box that's a fact they're
also the only to ever compete at the
Grand Master Level there you go you know
that's a one for one it gets to be
everyone's favorite only one to compete
only one to win but no seriously he's
the strongest chess player in the field
so if sir tag brings the chops on the
Clash side right okay let's go in Duo
number two on team Barbarian is
Ash and Anna kramling
now let's go over these Ash
es well they formally clashed with that
she like he's I take a lot of
inspiration from him but he's uh he's a
little washed up though so he's got ah
he's gotta he's gotta prove himself
today I feel like little washed up is
that how you describe Anna kramling in
chess is the opposite of what we would
say about Anna krambling she's uh she is
just getting started and she's she's a
star in chess chess commentary chess
player this will be a fun one I don't
know anything about Ash besides clash
with Ash Grimes and I am a sucker for
rhyme time so I'm now instantly a clash
with Ash fan oh he's a great guy he's a
great guy but I I don't know he's gonna
he's gonna flop a little bit when it
gets a Clash of Clans specifically but I
think he can hold his own in Clash
Royale okay well let's get over to Duo
number three halfway through team
Barbarian we got
X rohot
am I saying that right yeah there's an X
in there too yeah just real hot I
imagine and uh Alexandra botez uh which
should be pretty fearsome I believe
they're together on stream on
Alexandra's stream I could have made
that up but I'm pretty sure I saw them
could be lying yeah I thought I saw him
too I don't know if that was a thumbnail
that got displaced but I thought I saw
them too we'll go on team I spread
misinformation a lot yeah and our final
one uh final Duo of the team Barbarian
Domingo and Kevin boardy uh and Kevin is
French
sorry that is correct sir Kevin bordee
is French I was sipping some water here
you can tell just based on the mustache
yeah yeah no I think legally you're not
allowed to support that unless you're
it's only legal in this country you are
either a musketeer or a French streaming
chess player all right with that well
hey I'm looking forward to see all of
these Duos play how's Domingo
skilled
I don't know Domingo I don't know what I
mean that's great I mean it's a wild
card variable uh well the goal at the
end of the night is for supercell and
chess.com to help offer up money
not for the players but for charity
that's what's happening today it's a 50
000 tournament hoping to raise money for
healthy gamer Foundation which most
people in chat should know healthy gamer
Foundation a staple of the live
streaming space they help promote mental
health needs of the digital generation
uh and depending on the score of both
teams on the final challenge there is a
chance to have all fifty thousand
dollars get donated but first before we
get to there and get to that point and
figure out who's raising how much we
have to talk about our challenges we
have six total challenges today and our
first one is hand brain a classic love
me some hand brain uh this is kind of my
skill set I don't know Eric uh I'm a
champion
um in the Chess World like a lot if you
ask people most people know me because
of my hand brain w that I took down with
Robert Hess was currently in Kolkata
India hello Robert hope you're having a
good time we crushed like Northern Lions
the list is insane though like I'm
talking about you don't know these names
are celebrities crushing them all in a
handbrain event the way it works is very
simple the better chess player is going
to say a chess piece because they have
the whole game in their head like the
the person from that TV show when she
looks at the ceiling and then the The
Clash player is going to have to move
that piece but they're not going to know
where to move it to so you get a little
more information than if you played a
chess game played it raw but maybe you
aren't doing the plan that your coach
wants for you and that's the idea uh and
every Duo is going to go up against a
random Duo from the other team and the
team with the most victories wins The
Challenge does that make sense
loud and clear sir and I was gonna prop
you up as the maybe the reigning hand
and brain world champion but you propped
yourself so now I can't even do it now I
have to try to tear you up no you no
I'll do that to myself in fact you don't
even remember that the team you beat had
sardosh but then Kevin boardy was that
was the do you know Kevin board he was
there
Kevin calls the wrong piece bordee
that's what we call him anyway we are
ready to get into it hand brain we're
gonna look at four different matches at
the same time we'll bounce amongst the
matches they're all ten five ten minutes
total for the match five seconds per
move so let's go let's get it let's
watch some let's watch some dang chess
all right we're in Paris what better to
do than watch chess get me involved
um I impressed Everybody by the way you
did I walked in the production room I
was like guess he's best Meg and they're
like what what are you okay you sound
all right you sound all right I'm the
equivalent of a five-year-old and I'm
sitting I'm just impressed by you all
day walking around speaking French I'm
pretending like I understand a single
word sometimes I divorce it the
parisians are bastards because I went to
this I went to this coffee shop and I
was like uh bonjour and cappuccino but
the way I said it yeah yeah she knew I
was American so she's like uh that's
perfect would you like it was a bit of
sugar is that all and then I I tried to
force the French yeah I hear that they
do that my cousin is here in school uh
for like a French Foreign Exchange thing
and she says that if you walk in and you
don't carry the accent they just
switched to English yeah for whatever
reason the moment I walked in the door
they already just started English
talking English to me because they just
knew before I even said anything I don't
know what it is Eric I could tell you
it's about 200 things
the list is long but we don't need to
talk about that we need to talk about
the hand brain which I think we're are
we in it we're we're back can we peep
over are we at one by the way you might
be wondering okay what do you get if you
win a challenge as the team like what
what's the point of it basically all six
challenges will get you a bonus for the
final Challenge and the final challenge
is all the marbles so everything is just
in the lead up to that and the the thing
that it gets you is a Time Advantage the
final challenge is going to be Clash of
Clans your wheelhouse and they get a two
minute bonus if they had won a previous
challenge how important is two extra
minutes that sounds like a lot of time
to me
I'd say every one to three minutes well
two minutes on average right yeah is
gonna give them probably an extra two
stars which is obviously an extra two
thousand dollars for charity but then
also it is two extra stars for their
team and so every challenge win here is
gonna be a big Advantage depending on
what they end up getting drawn in the
ladder and if you're like Okay cool so
it all goes to charity regardless of
whether you win or lose what do you get
if you win if you're the winning team we
get a couple of things first off
chess.com you guys are offering a bot
for all eight people that's that's not
that big of a deal to you because you've
had a bot for a long time it is a big
deal to me okay my bot is actually one
of my most tweeted out things about me
because I'll do like nothing I'll be
gone for like a week like right now I'm
in Paris I'm in I'm in Paris doing
Parisian things when when POG Champs
first started the whole chess collab
thing and you had a bot and then
eventually it became a thing where we
had to say no to people because everyone
wanted one so it is you know we're
giving away some people always message
me when they beat my boss some people
are like your butts better than you I'm
like that's not true that's hurtful
that's hurtful so they all get a bot uh
and on supercell's side The Clash side
they get a bunch of dope things in class
so they're gonna give away so if you're
a viewer of one of the people who win or
maybe not a viewer go to their chat at
the last second if you play Clash
because you'll get free stuff anyway we
are in the hand brain game and we're
looking at Amman Hamilton who is giving
them the pieces to move for sir tag
sir tag
who is who's actually forced to make the
moves
and who is Sir tag in Amman Hamilton
playing against good question
uh yeah it's actually right here it's OJ
and virtual oh uh this is gonna be
embarrassing a stomp virtuals okay so
virtual's like he won the constellation
bracket he's like a thousand rated yeah
he's giving advice to someone who's like
like paper won at chess I imagine OJ has
no experience he's like 200 rated right
so like you put in a thousand and a 200
together you might get a lower rating
than you might you might have the rare
effect of getting worse yes together
which almost is almost impossible and
Amman is cracked out of his mind 20 like
700 2800 like yeah isn't he didn't hit
like insane scores OTV OTB for those who
don't speak French in chess means over
the board he's about 25.50 but online
I'm on his 3 000. I mean he's a
fantastic Blitz player but if you're
giving peace advice to somebody who
doesn't know what they're doing and
you're that Talent of a player like they
also have to think about like do I give
am I gonna if I'm not gonna choose an
over complicated piece to move there and
then not be able to see it you know
because they aren't going to be able to
see your grand plan because they don't
they're doing it's a great point they're
making a great point but I think the
right brain the right brain can guide
the hand to do the right thing I mean
blood can speak from experience on this
I can speak from experience on this
Earth it's it's the brain's job to make
sure that they guide you in a way that
you could not like
f up all right to put bluntly uh so yeah
we are in it here I was wrong at light
earlier they're not in the same room but
we do have Alexandra playing with rohot
she's playing those spell chest there uh
she don't use any of the premiers know
the games are starting okay I think
Amman was in analysis and then she's
playing spell chess so let me tell you
it's like
being disconnected in Paris for a little
bit they have it right over here all
these streamers and their own bubbles
not adhering the schedules
it makes me sick frankly it makes me
sick and you guys can't read it but my
chat right now is there's a bunch of
yeses and smiley faces because I believe
in being on time yeah and I'm sure what
time today so like that makes sense yeah
you're right on time I love by the way
can I just call out that you quickly go
from professional news Anchorman which
suits you to then like what is the
it's it's the you know nightclub DJ
delivering some sort of my bad I'm six
foot three all right a meter 89 okay
this this chair is not I'm look if I put
it down look at this hello chat hello
see that see how that's an issue I feel
that I gotta hold you just gotta you
gotta embrace the hunch uh really lean
into it you know my posture's too good
these days
um I think this is this still spell
chess spell chest we're going to see
later on by the way belchest is the
combination of of Chess and and Clash is
that gonna be playable for people at
home
it is playable right now you go to yeah
you just go to the chess.com variant
server if you just Google spell chess
I'm sure you'll get a link to it
um but yeah it's actually a lot of fun
anybody can plan cool and uh we'll cover
the rules of it later when it comes up
in the show but you were telling it to
me and I was like that sounds fun like I
would like to have the power ups in my
opponent doesn't sounds chaotic that's
what it sounds like well it's funny
because we always thought of what we
would do if we started combining
elements like that but you can't really
mess with chess it's sacred right don't
don't fix it it you know it's not broken
but this collab gave us the excuse is
this loyal stuff you made chess two yeah
we did that's it chest 2.0 well I would
say chest 2.0 was was Ludwig chess maybe
that was chess 1.5 yeah okay like The
Lion King movie you know
I'm with you on that okay I'm seeing
everybody is prepared and ready to join
battle
I have a fantasy football draft right as
the show ends
that these streamers don't make me
missed it because by God I picked up
Cooper cup and then I found out that
he's on the injured reserved list and
that's killed my season in one of my
I've got a great team by the way and
your fantasy league
oh an auction which is actually a lot of
fun at first I was like this is so much
work I can't believe and do this is it a
bunch of chest nerds in it no no it's a
a league with with some friends I can
probably say it's rain rain Wilson's
League it's not like oh my God what
you're so annoying right I mean who
drops that invited you asked so this is
a bunch of celebrities in it but I'm not
gonna name those names yeah I know it's
just me Ray my buddy Uh Kevin Hart I
don't know if you've heard of him oh
rain's calling me right now okay yeah
no but actually so it's it's an auction
League which at first I thought this is
gonna be a pain in the ass oh wait we're
in it we got okay okay stop talking
about rain Daniel rain Wilson we got yes
I hang out with many famous people have
you heard of Nikki England
okay anyway here it is our first match
it's going to be Gotham chest and sapnap
which is a very powerful Duo against
blitzstream in Domingo so at this point
I guess it's worth talking about
blitzstream's chest skill is it
comparable to Gotham chess it is
actually it's pretty comparable and and
Kevin is is a fantastic Blitzen bullet
player I I don't have their chess.com
ratings live in front of me but I would
imagine that Levy and Kevin are actually
pretty close
um but you know we keep you know coming
back to this and now now we're no longer
joking being serious I'll say in the
strategy of hand and brain often the
most important player is the hand and
I'm not just saying that because Ludwig
is next to me and he won that event with
Hess ultimately it really does come down
to the hand whoever the if the hand is
stronger it's him saying it Eric I'm not
saying this yeah yeah they win are they
on a timer as well are they being
pressured yep right there so you see the
uh the clocks next to the usernames
ticking down so right now what what the
hell was that queen move
that might have been the dumbest thing
I've ever seen in my life am I crazy no
so is that the worst move the problem is
black has you see Queen H4 check is
coming at some point yeah so you have to
watch out for that and the Queen on E2
actually guards E4 so it kind of keeps
the the tactics at Bay here black gives
the check with the queen so it's not the
worst um it's not the best but it's not
the worst so I'm seeing Domingo's rating
I don't know if it's accurate but
they're currently put at
1277. I do think sapnaps rating is
accurate so that would mean that the
hand is much stronger for Domingo Blitz
as opposed to sapnap Gotham which I'm
surprised by that's a very high rate
that's an impressive rating it's
now and I know I'm getting old so my
memory's coming back to me this makes
sense because Kevin has been pushing for
us to invite Domingo to pogchamps for a
long time and we just never did so now
I'm like wait maybe we should have
because he's like he's 1200 although he
might have been the best player in the
field that's like my rating right now
and he's not I mean you're seeing this
it's not like he's playing like the
rating is wrong right he's developed his
pieces he's gotten his King safe he's up
on the or I guess even on the clock so
Domingo looks like uh he's doing doing
great uh yeah I feel like he's I mean
you're you're the position a reader
you're you like playing these little
games you go do your chess broadcast and
I really feel like you're not even
broadcasting at times I feel like you're
just playing a game of who's in the lead
yeah with with Donya whoever your
co-host is so right here if you had to
make a call who's in the lead
um
very equal but I like Black's position
and the reason is I'll show you the
black king is castled so you see it's
safe on the edge of the board and the
White Queen blocks the white Bishop the
white Bishop blocks the white rook in
the corner and so you have one of these
old ladies who swallowed the fly and uh
there's less highlighting and what he
was highlighting right there is what
white needs to do which is push the pawn
the G Pawn so that you can move the
bishop so you can get castled so he was
kind of in fact he's highlighting it now
and he can't hear me his whole point and
thank you Levy for participating his
whole point is he's highlighting that
white has development problems I'll buy
her book when it comes out yeah so okay
white seems to be in a bit of trouble
this is our opening for this game Let's
bounce over to another game just to see
where we are at at the same time we'll
come back to this one in a moment maybe
we can take a look at OJ virtual sir tag
and Amman Hamilton if that game is up
and ready to go around the horn uh and
just basically take a look at all four
games uh
and then check back in later you know we
gotta we gotta by the way Eric
this has to be you have to ask
you have just all the questions you can
because when we get class going I'm
gonna look like the dumbest yeah yeah
new questions and so if you're like hey
what's going on this is the opportunity
to be like this doesn't make any sense
Danny frankly me versus you interested
you look like the dumbest person in the
world all the time I'm literally so much
better than you uh is this the only game
going this might be the only game that
we have right now
oh well let's take a look let's bounce
over we've got the other games
well so we'll see what happened there so
Levy said pawn and remember how this
works everyone is the the chess player
is the brain so they say the piece but
the hand has to choose the piece like I
was saying and ultimately the hand can
really win the game or really effing
bleep up the game and in that position
Levy said bishop and sapnap did not
choose the right Bishop so we'll see if
that comes back but all right let's take
it away we're on a new game I don't even
know who we're looking at we are on a
new game and I believe that says sir tag
at the bottom if my eyes are good and
they are which means this is Sir tag uh
POV and uh sir tag is being led by Amman
Hamilton uh and they're going up against
OJ who is being led by virtual so this
should
by all intents and purposes if chess is
an honest Sport and handbrain is a
legitimate battle be a wash Amman
Hamilton should crush the mind of
virtual as the brain and it shouldn't
matter if the hand outmatches the other
hand
you are not wrong sir although I've
never hand and brain as one of those
less explored territories so I've never
seen a mission like the ocean yeah like
it's like the ocean unexplored
Eric when you look at this what do you
see as a as a chess master as a chess as
with my kind of Chester here's the thing
your brain in chess is about as good as
chat's brain and chest like me and Danny
are pros of the game so what you see is
very valuable because it'll determine
what chat sees yeah so what like you're
looking at this who do you think's
having a good time who do you think's
having a bad time black or white well
right now it looks like White's in a
little bit of a bind there with the
queen all the way up there forward like
it looks like but he can't move the
queen because the Queen's pinned to the
king both of the Queens are pinned on
each other oh my God Eric wait what's
your chest rating did you just bust it
like terminology like 200 okay all right
you're dropping on a really good day you
know like it's uh like I know I know the
terminology I just uh I I gotta play a
bit more yeah I got I got I'm about at
the same level as I think the Barbarian
bought on right now all right there you
go very impressive well I think one
thing to note here and Danny I hope you
back me up is I guess two things is
actually first thing black is having a
tough time protecting the king because
of that Bishop which is why they're
trading it off uh but also white is
struggling a bit on time and when Queens
are off the board it's a little it's a
little Lamer of a game there's a lot
less action yep it gets traded down to
end game a lot faster and especially in
hand brain where it becomes like a
cheese fest of of I mean candidly
cheating at the end yeah because people
are moving before their brain tells them
what to move yep time matters a lot I
think uh like especially when it's like
timed and stuff like that like if I was
playing I feel like I'd play very very
aggressively and trade a lot of pieces
and just try to like Beat the Clock you
know because uh I if I have less pieces
on the board then I when they tell me
that I'm going to play a certain piece
then I know that it's that one because I
only have one of them and I know I
limits my options down a lot
of the Mind of a hand right now of an
insecure hand yeah but still that's
actually really interesting I haven't
really thought about that I I think
you're probably right and they're
probably playing fast in trading
although Ludwig you made a great point
that the bishop was the problem and so
that's why I'm on
told him to take it with the Knight
um now we're back to a pretty equal
position you see both Kings have gotten
their their both sides have gotten their
kings out of the center
both sides are going to be developing
their pieces Iman must have just said
Knight this is an interesting process
right the brain says the piece the hand
goes and touches the piece sees all the
legal squares it can go to makes a
decision from there
um well let's just tap it off here this
is a in Danny's words equal position and
the only real Advantage for black is the
time which is pretty glaring at the
moment but it's still anyone's game and
we'll jump over to our other two games
which are happening right now again
whichever team wins the most game wins
Advantage for this round so the next one
we have is Christine uh Christini and
Maestro
you're saying it wrong
that's how people identify themselves
Christina how about just Christine
Christine Christine Christina with
Maestro Luis against rohot in Alexandra
this game Danny just are just give me
your what are your plums saying first
thing I have to give a shout out to
because you and I haven't talked about
this yet probably the biggest snub we
made for pogchamps five together with
the invites we did is on screen right
now Christine was not happy she didn't
get an invite she has been grinding
chess ever since she played pogchamps
for she takes weekly lessons with Anna
Rudolph
and she loves chess
and she was really so I'm saying that
now because wow
if we do that thing again I may or may
not have already kind of promised we
would make it up to her I'm just saying
so I actually take partial blame because
I invited foosli's uh ass who should not
have been invited
crucibly flounder you know look at her
look at the way she you can tell some of
the experience look how quickly she
highlights look at she's she's a she's a
channel she looks still like a rockstar
out there you know fusley can't even win
her on TV Tuesday so it's like she's
she's pointing out her opponent's
threats the bishop is starting to take
the pawn she's pointing out that the
Knight can take the pawn so you know
Louis luisan is not as good as a mon or
or Kevin bordee maybe as a chess player
but he might have maybe one of the
better hands that we haven't talked
about yet and so we'll this is going to
be an interesting team I like that extra
that move at the night there where like
she would have had to tell him to use or
move that Bishop because the the night
was about to Fork two different units
the queen and the bishop there so
luckily got out of the way there but
they still end up taking the move with
the Knight which is interesting is there
a play to that because she did the right
move so she she must have been suggested
to move a knight oh but it doesn't work
but it could you have to get rid of you
have to get rid of the bishop
so maybe the pawn moved she sees it uh
yes that's what I was thinking we're
both in the same wavelength wait she's
got a chest what the heck no she's good
um this makes sense right you push the
pawn and then you're trying to get rid
of the bishop which is defending your
fork Square yep so maybe you should just
go like all the way back or something
right is that smart yeah so right now
who is the who's the brain for the
opponent what a big whiff because now
you just do the fork and you win the
queen GG he sees it well of course
because the move the move set here was
Knight which I guess could have been
interpreted as Savior night move your
night away but he's gonna oh she sees is
she's a baller look at so this is it I
think we're seeing early early signs of
a luisan Christina knee and now I really
have to say her name right out of
respect
I like her excitement right there
because like you you saw that as soon as
they made that wrong move there that uh
she saw it and then as soon as they
moved the knight in that position and
unfortunately then you know that they
they actually got under control and I
hate to call it early oh what a good
look on the bishop too
oh my God anyway dude she's setting up
checkmate with Queen D like she's okay
okay now white did play the best in
which egg but it doesn't matter she's
gonna put the king to safety and she's
already all over it she sees the bishop
on the line as you said Ludwig like
let's just call it she's Subway certain
times christening is is the God of this
of this match this is a win for team
King I don't see a world in which uh she
doesn't close it out uh so let's move
over to our final game which we haven't
taken a look at which is probably
already pretty deep into it uh which is
zocus and Rey Enigma versus Ash and Anna
uh in this game we see Ray Enigma on the
screen both of them actually on the
screen Ray and zocus and this position
is dubious that's the words that
commentators say when I don't think they
know what to say that
first of all thank you for calling that
out uh dubious I actually like to use
interesting interesting when I have no
idea what to say
um this is a dubiously interesting
position and I'm just looking at Rey
Enigma and I'm my mind is blown that
this is what he's doing he's yelling at
his teammate you can't see his lips
but you can tell by the way he's
gesturing that he's he's got a lot of
emotion behind his suggestions but
you're not allowed to say I mean
generally you're only allowed to say the
the piece is that what was that but he
must have said Bishop just a regular
trade okay occasionally a team will slip
up and we won't hold it against them but
it is really important for the fans and
chat to understand that you are not
allowed to say like
I'm saying Bishop think about your dark
squares think about the center point
like you got to shut up you say the
piece and that's it every once in a
while they break the rules a little bit
and we have to remind them and um anyway
during when I was watching uh Ash's
video he's doing a practice session with
Anna kremling and she was feeding him
the line like trying to practice the the
hand brain thing there and she would
name a piece and he would sit there and
stare at it for like five ten minutes
and he just couldn't figure it out as
couldn't figure it out so I'm like I'm
not sure what his uh practice sessions
have looked like since then but uh Happy
step
well right now they have one advantage
which is a couple minutes on the clock
they are going up against Ash of clash
Formerly Known the art is formerly known
as Ash of clash not just ash uh and Anna
kramling uh what What's the position
who's winning
they actually clashed with Ash's team
right if I'm looking they're the ones up
two minutes here right because clash
with Ash is white clash with Ash OH are
you correct about that yeah no so then I
don't know how to read a board no it's
okay I was right I was right I'm only
clarifying because I've I've done um
I've made much bigger mistake but yeah
clash with Ash and Anna krambling are
definitely playing faster it makes me
wonder if Randy yeah passion was like
you gotta speed up bro
um but look at this both sides are
saying pawns Ludwig and the you know
what the players are playing like
they're not playing like like they're
the world champion hand because when
they when they hear Pawn they're making
just like a safe pawn move they're not
really they're doing the thing where
they're afraid to solve the position
right and super common in handbranched
they're just making Rinky Dink pawn
moves yeah a hanging Pond no yeah the
opponent A6 is hanging
Grand Master Lut over here I see things
with my eyes and but also my heart
uh well this game if you had to pick a
person in the lead which color is it
this is
I don't even I feel like I as a chess
player I need to reject and refuse to
answer that this is this is a dead equal
position where neither side is ready to
win a chess game yet but because I have
to choose I will choose white because of
what you already said they're all
committed on the clock and there really
isn't anything else to the position it's
completely equal both sides have all
their Pawns all their nights it's okay
now c4 is a horrible move okay let's see
what happens here because Anna said pawn
and Ash moved a bad pawn and they're
just gonna lose it okay black is winning
difficult for a player doesn't have a
ton of experience like you say Pawn
there's so many different options and
yeah they're not going to see the bigger
picture they're they're not super
experienced so when you open up that big
of a can of worms like you don't know
what's gonna happen just kind of playing
a wild card there is the brain what
you're saying is where Grand Master
Robert Hess and that duo would that he
had with Ludwig got gets a lot of the
credit because an experienced brain will
avoid opportunities for the hand to
blunder they will not play pieces that
lead to a bunch of nebulous decisions um
Eric we were we were electric yeah we're
etched in pyramids yeah let's get over
to another game which is somewhat
similar although I guess there was a bit
of a shift in the wins there uh let's go
back to our sapnap Gotham game because
that had a pretty equal position
although you felt very good perhaps
about Domingo in blitzstream yeah uh and
let's see if you still feel that way
because some time has passed now oh
we're deep in it oh wow we are the other
we are far along yeah and Domingo you
thought was in the lead and they are now
certainly in the lead yeah so they're at
the exchange in chess and exchange means
there's there's the same quantity of
pieces but you have the better pieces so
if you look at Black's pieces black has
two Rooks and white has a rook and a
knight so objectively black has won the
exchange even though all sides have four
pieces besides the king so that's some
quick chest terminology White's King is
also wide open
um but I will say this like
as much as a grand master wins this wins
this position 100 times out of 100 is
black there's some there's some
weirdness to this and it's because
Knights for amateur players are very
tricky they're they're blunderable it's
actually in a very strong Square there
in the center and this move G4 from
sapnab if him and Levy just start
rushing the Pawns
look at the fact that Domingo only has
two and a half minutes so yeah
I'm just saying
so question about the like the rules in
the hand brain if they say a piece do
they have to move out okay and look he
okay he said Knight and sapnap sees it
is a great move this is a discovered
attack on the queen because moving the
Knight actually attacks the queen with
the Rook do not move the Knight there no
go for he had the right idea and he's
overthinking wouldn't it be better to do
a little bait here okay yeah he
he sorry say that again I mean why not
throw the Knight on E6 do a little bait
you know actually that was that was even
better
96 and so I just I I just see things
Eric are you you must be the hand are
you bloodwig of the hand and brain
championship team again pyramids so the
reason everybody is that the Knight on
E6 would have been attacking The Rook on
f8 along with that discovery of that
Rook on F4 attacking the queen on C4
right now so Ludwig actually saw the
better move better than I did 96 was the
best move they actually wouldn't let me
compete in this I asked to clash your
chest and they they barred me because
they thought I was too good at each game
yeah he's over he's a commentator for a
reason
um but I want to come back to the reason
I like Knight F5 though too because
Knight F5 gets closer to the king and
there's all kinds of ways that this
turns into a mating net meaning mating
net is just when you you know a net and
you're trying to mate actually that got
awkward real quick what I'm trying to
say is a meeting that in chess is short
for checkmate and it's when you have a
bunch of pieces around the king and they
can only get tighter and bad things
happen so this is horrible yeah the
amount of time that was taken and up for
that and I don't know if I'm correct by
saying this dog water move yep was that
dog water it was there's two good moves
here Knight to D6 Forks so there's no
way Levy doesn't say night night to D6
Forks the queen and Rook so a fork is
when you attack both yeah Knight E7
check is actually a crazy move and it's
why I like Knight F5 I was hoping for
tactics like this because after 97 check
the Rook can't go backward everybody
without losing the queen The Rook takes
the queen and if the king moves
did Levy say Rook Levy said Rook which I
actually agree with keep a sample stupid
you know well the queen or the
yeah the queen never mind no I'm not I'm
seeing the wrong things here I'm I'm in
the mind of the the hand there and I'm
thinking all the wrong things there and
I'm like yeah you're like in this high
pressure situation where the time is
ticking down really really fast and uh
it's just like in like Clash of Clans
and Clash Royale when you're in a high
pressure situation it starts you just
start to get uh tunnel visioned and yeah
everything goes black you can't see
anymore I'm a little nervous about this
so Levy just said night yeah and the
issue is the Queen's currently being
attacked yeah he has to see 97. so you
have to check yeah that's the only
reason that you would move the Knight
and I feel like he does see this he's
calculating through it makes the check
good move sapnap they got more time to
work with too you don't have time for
love analysis but I'm actually gonna
revert on what I said and say Levy made
the right call not to go for this not
because 97 wasn't good that I was saying
but if he had said night sapnap would
have played the wrong night move and I'm
thinking about that would have been a
bad idea so you're right Ludwig saying
Rook was probably the best thing for
hand and brain even though 97 check
earlier was better you don't want to
swag out too much that's what they say
in the sport
did he say night again no he said Queen
here we go Queen F4 is a good move it
blocks the checks if you actually don't
put the queen there then the white king
is open on the diagonal I don't know
where the other games are at but this is
exciting and I'm dialed in yeah I think
we should wrap this one up before
bouncing to another game here yeah just
because there's there's some drama here
okay what was the point of that a good
move from blitzstream kick out the night
move the rook in the in the way now the
time's about equal here I'm a little
nervous a little nervous for a little
sapnap and Gotham chest
this is the clout team
[Laughter]
[Music]
a horrible gross blunder oh nasty nasty
little blunder from Robert your boy
talks about this a lot retreating moves
are the hardest moves to see like it's
almost
this is Jehovah this is Joker for other
games lud because in other games like
there's this you go around or you go
forward there isn't a lot of retreating
right and and Gamers who are switching
to chess like they don't look for
retreating moves like you do and so what
happened there was he just didn't think
about the queen going back can I keep it
a bug with you yeah I love Robert I
don't think he drops much wisdom that's
not worth listening to I disagree on
this point yeah sapnap's just dumb okay
the next game we got to take a look at
OJ virtual sir tag in Amman Hamilton
we're almost assuredly going to see a
win here for Domingo in blitzstream
which is big for team Barbarian but this
is our other game in 39 seconds on the
clock let's let's bear this one out that
is not a lot of time yeah and there are
not a lot of pieces on the board it
seems pretty damn equal yeah I mean OJ
and who's on a virtual virtual and OJ
yeah this this could be the upset of the
event they are going up against Iman
Hamilton right right this is the
strongest player yeah on chess versus
the weakest player on chess I don't know
how else to say it I want to say team
chess because it's not really team chess
but this has been this is amazing ooh
Knight
I'm sure virtual called it out
for the move Knight C6 yeah what does
that do it just attacks oh yeah don't
say that don't do that it attacks The
Rook the bishop might take but it
doesn't
but we'll see this could be where Amman
gets the better of virtual because
virtual is a is a very good player we
saw that in POG Champs especially when
he has time
but if he starts playing moves like this
like Amman just said Bishop
yeah and this is not a good move I saw
this move yeah but I just did it because
there's a move to see the issue is that
that open E file imagine there's not
much action you can do because there's
nowhere for the The Rook to go because
the king defends so many squares and
then the Rook defense the final Square
it's like what are you supposed to do
yep uh Pawn probably a call here I'm
imagining G3 comes oh it's a rook Hall
he said Rook so this is scary okay
that's a very good move OJ is how good
is OJ and chess made I'm just
underestimating the hand on this team
okay swagging out a bit
time is super low though like
concerningly low oh yeah
move up on more perhaps
okay if you give up the phone oh God
if you put the Rook on that's where
Amman will say King immediately yeah and
we'll see how fast or tag can can see
the king coming forward yeah
oh look at this the time is crazy close
25 seconds each and exactly like you
called it King came forward to defend
his pawns the move call was was Pawn I
believe we should Pawn Yeah okay I'm
assuming should be F3 it's the only move
12 seconds though not a lot of time I
feel like they just need to make meth
fast moves like I don't know if
anybody's King specifically win here but
like just tie another person out by
going faster all right GG get it GG I
think it was probably a bad call for
virtual to say Pawn there right I agree
hoping for the one F3 move I don't even
know if that was good if he had done F3
was it it was it was the only move at
that point but it it black was already
getting better you're right and now Pawn
was probably a call to capture on G4
that was a whiff and this means that
we're almost definitely going to see a
win for sir tag and Amman Hamilton
although almost made the upset which
means two likely likely two wins for
team Barbarian let's take a look at our
third match this one we thought was
going to be a watch uh a wash with uh
Christine Nini and Maestro luison uh
let's take a look see if it is still a
wash because this would mean team King
has some hope here
maybe it's already done yes as long as
uh but as long as a modern search you
know me I'm I'm still the POG Champs
hangover is real they generally lasts
several months until you've had enough
you know juice and eggs and all the
things you need what do you eat normally
I I I'm thinking that there's a
stalemate possible and pogchamps does
that to you it's a girl diet uh I feel
like it will be tough
and we do see a
a lost screen off in there
it seems like
this is
if I'm correct about this yeah Christina
knew one that was what we thought
Christina anyone yeah I am Christine and
he took down
um I'm pretty sure this is rohot zohot
Arizona's
partner okay okay all right uh which
means the only other game to take a look
at is Ray Enigma and Ash
yeah
which is crambling and clash with Ash
versus
how's that not check my garden it is
Checkmate it's over okay
uh
uh and that game is still going all
right so this game kind of determines it
yeah because Christina got a win for
team King there's two team Barbarian
teams that are poised to win barring a
stalemate so this either was going to
create the Thai 2-2 or give team
Barbarian the win
the Enigma and uh
and uh I'm seeing a hung horse here yeah
this is just this is fantastic for black
they're up a queen yeah you see that too
I see that too
so what is this so this girl seeing that
horse
right Rey enigma
and zokas are on team King
so yeah team King is actually
I don't know I've lost track of this let
me let me let me do this brother I have
you we're watching along with zocus and
so that means they are winning this
match yeah and they are also on team
King which would mean this is the most
perfectly balanced teams because team
King is gonna get two wins in team
Barbarian is gonna get two wins now it's
not totally in the bag this one seems
pretty locked
uh because I mean they're up a whole
Queen and Rook trade
now he sees it
yup okay yeah now they're up they're up
juicy
they're up juicy this is over they're
also up on the clock so there isn't that
practical concern of just panicking
right so this looks so unless any of
those other games went the way we didn't
predict then you're right man we're
deadlocked at two games a piece and what
happens if it's a tie well nothing
actually it's just again a challenge to
help for the final round if it's a tie
both teams get one extra minute it
doesn't really do much that is Checkmate
right there they offered up mate in one
that was very sweet of them kind is that
a full body morph suit yeah he's yeah he
doesn't kid around this is not a I don't
think he gets out of that thing doesn't
have his candy just has checks then we
know for sure that he doesn't live in
Paris because there's no air
conditioning and it is 95 here uh it
looks like a draw wait wait what they
still made or what
I told you POG Champs lives gives people
like those panic attacks wait
wait who was that with the that was
against sir tag that was OJ in a virtual
well it doesn't wait does that that
changes everything everything that
changes everything
what a huge massive ugly blunder
so this stalemate between the two
mean that sir tag and Iman Hamilton are
no longer going to get the win
no is it yeah and so then it's going to
be a win for Christianity which already
happened a win for Rey Enigma which
already happened yep and a draw for OJ
and virtual
which means that they win yeah that
means team team King takes it team King
takes it two and a half whoa team King
with the w
yep there we see the screen uh and we
don't have the results of that final
match where sapnap and Gotham chess were
almost assuredly losing but it doesn't
matter because even if uh wait no wait
Ash and Anna wins it's still not GG
right is that if that's not over let's
go back there yeah
it's wrong okay great yeah we got it we
got we did our math right we did our man
we're good at our job we're good at our
job so there it is there it is that's a
W-4 team King which means they are
receiving a two-minute Advantage for the
final round uh and that that's pretty
big and again if you guys are just
tuning in welcome it's chess it's clash
it's one esport that they have combined
somehow uh and what we are doing here
today is we are playing both games in as
many ways as you can play them uh and
it's all in preparation for the final
challenge which is The Clash of Clans
raid challenge yeah uh and all these six
challenges give you a uh up to two
minute bonus
for that final challenge that's it
you're just basically playing for a
little extra time for your final thing
of the day uh and the more time you have
at the end presumably the better you'll
do it I think that's right to say Eric
more money you can win the more money
you can win for charity that's right
well
and all the giveaways for the viewers as
well for the channels that they win what
do I win you want to make a bet let's do
it I I will put 100
no I will bet the entirety of Mogul
moves and you bet the entirety of
chess.com
even trade I'm gonna pick randomly uh
Team King you get team Barbarian chicken
it's just I'm legally authorized to do
this so there you go he won't offer up
his main Channel
I'm gonna be worth billions soon okay so
man anyway here are the teams I got team
king that's team Ludwig now you can take
a look at them we got people like Gotham
chess sapnap
Christianity yeah other people she's the
she's the winner over there man that was
the most important
my whole team oh 10 000 steps today
wow it's right there that was my last
step that was my last step handshake for
chest doctor got lost to Mogul moves I
got crazy here uh we're about to hop
into our Second Challenge and basically
every challenge kind of Hops uh to it to
a different sort of thing this one is
Clash of Clans ladder attack now you
guys have been doing all the talking now
it's time for me to kick in here right
I'm excited to let you jump in man yeah
wait is that chest real
whoa
the chest I didn't that I saw the chest
on the broadcast I didn't know if it was
real in real life but it is I I know I
watched well now we can see it so yeah
uh there's nothing in it I'm also
wearing no shoes under this desk and no
pants but nobody knows that okay ladder
attack sorry Eric take it away thank you
for sharing uh so okay so what they're
gonna do here for the ladder attacks is
that each of the players are gonna do
two attacks there random attacks there
on the ladder and they're gonna add up
the stars that they're able to get so
now there's no Clash of Clans like very
proficient players here to my knowledge
so maybe there's some maybe there's some
other dogs hiding out there that I
didn't realize there were just uh class
Geniuses and they can they can come out
here and surprise us but I expect some
uh simple attacks probably to come out
here and see if they can gather up a
couple Stars here and then we'll add up
all the stars from each of the teams and
we'll see what happens but the the
non-clash players are gonna have to play
and then The Clash players are gonna
have to be their guide to be able to
actually get them to go through so it's
going to be like the hand and brain
except for it's going to be Clash of
Clans version of it so we we'll see
because Clash of Clans is you're
reacting in real time that you're not
having turns
okay I
I don't know if I mentioned this to you
Eric because this is actually kind of an
exciting format I'm really good at hand
brain uh for this mode I'm the hand what
would my brain be telling me
well a lot of times when Clash of Clans
a lot of whether you succeed or fail is
going to be based on how you can because
if you know Clash of Clans then you know
that when you drop your troops they're
just going to follow their AI after the
moment you drop them you lose control
over them so a lot of Clash of Clans is
is setting up a position to be able to
get the troops to go to where you want
them to go because once they drop
they're out of they're just going to
follow their AI you don't have any
weight to actually maneuver them anymore
so what they need to do is have the the
brain as you want to call it would need
to show them how to set a a funnel to
actually like trim certain buildings out
to try to drop the main Force to go in
funnel what's this this must be
all the way into it the people are
talking opening Theory at chess this
must be what it's like for them yes
bring me back to day dot okay there's I
imagine there's value based off where
you drop them is that right well they
there's value for what they can claim so
certain or lots of troops will have
different anti-trip counts that they can
cost to be able to take onto the field
and so if they over commit into one area
they're going to have less for another
area so you only have a certain amount
of army camp space before you just run
out and so you're going to have to
utilize exactly what you need into a
small area to try to to like trim out a
couple buildings in on one side of the
where the force is going to enter and on
the other side to make sure you like
create a lane into the base there so if
we see that then I'll definitely make
sure we're calling it out there to see
if they actually have a good funnel
because if they're going to be attacking
on a ladder a lot of the ladders are
going to put bases they're going to have
like the Town Hall in the very middle of
the base and if they don't put a proper
funnel and they just kind of let
everything go then it's all the wild
west out there and they'll know exactly
if they can actually get to the middle
of the base there or not so basically in
ladder mode they're going up against a
random team they're not going up against
each other here correct this is not PVP
I mean it kind of is but really in
ladder mode it's just someone defending
their base they're not not equally
attacking your base right exactly and
that also means there may be a little
bit of a luck Factor there if they get a
fair match up or not because you don't
know exactly when you're just attacking
a random base on a ladder you could end
up getting somebody who is a little bit
higher level than you or a little bit
lower level and that can make three
stars definitely possible and possibly
able to get the one stars or lower as
well so it's a pub stomp in each Duo of
the two teams plays two random attacks
which means that we're not only going to
see the chess players play twice but
also the actual Clash pros play twice is
that right are they playing I thought it
was each Duo plays once each Duo does
two attacks I think the player always
plays and The Clash player always
coaches okay so but they're but we're
gonna see them they get two chances and
you said when a game starts how much
time do they have once the attack starts
once they start dropping troops then
they have they have three minutes until
the timer expires and it's a long time
so and considering they don't need to
get anything other than stars and
they're not trying to fight for like
extra percentage or going after like a
specific amount of a loot on the
baseline or anything like that like as
long as they can get 50 of the base
they're taken out and get the town hall
down they should build a net two stars I
think any team that can score a three
star is probably gonna win any team who
throws because of one star is probably
gonna is gonna probably lose this can we
can we take a look at Gotham chess's POV
because I really want to see him play
this I have to ask three stars because
you you there's no reason to rush it
right would be the most impressive thing
it means you destroy the entirety of
their base and their Town Hall
how what is what is this Army
composition this is okay this
is a terrible terrible larvae but the
luck please
okay we're about to start here why is it
terrible well it's got a weird mix of
air and ground troops at the same time
which is definitely gonna hit him high
and hit him low that's what they say
yeah but every defense in Clash of Clans
has specific targeting and so like the
Cannons and the mortars and stuff like
that will only shoot ground troops
whereas you have like air defenses and
they're only going to be able to shoot
the air troops so you're trying to if
you mix it then you're getting hit on
both sides then you just you overall
only have a certain amount of HP pool of
your troops so if you're trying to throw
a mixed air and ground attack then
you're probably setting yourself for a
disadvantage Levy looks foolish Levy
looks like a fool right now is he
playing foolishly but is Levy the
attacker or the one with the King he's
attacking well he did just make a very
very big mistake there because he put in
his uh Grand Warden and the grand Warden
has the option to toggle to air or
ground and he put him on air during the
ground portion of attack
dude imagine
really bad for you guys
was really low on defensive levels and
so if you get that town hall down he's
probably gonna triple anyways even with
a very terrible he's gonna trip we
already got a store wait I thought we
were trying to make fun of a second star
I think he's no the base is very under
leveled here he got really lucky on the
look of it so he just random rolled a
trash base he did and so maybe a three
star which I was hyping up as something
that would be almost impossible is not
that impossible what's the big pink
looking Buffalo that's walking around oh
he's gone now that's the uh the yak each
of the heroes the stars that that's it
wow yeah he rocked it must think he got
lucky he got really really lucky that
that base was very out of the ordinary
is very under leveled which is like in
Clash of Clans like you have the option
once all your buildings are built for a
certain Town Hall level that you can
just upgrade your main building and you
can keep on getting your town hall to go
up and you have all your other buildings
lagging behind you swap to a different
game
you're just doing too much with the air
I'm trying to translate this back to the
chess audience so that's like playing on
all sides of the board not thinking
about anything okay here's Anna
the terrible posture by the way like do
you think about that when you're playing
like let's get your neck up a little bit
oh You Gotta Be You Gotta lean into it
you know uh okay she's going after so
she's a town hall 14 and she's attacking
her luck of the draw there was even
better than the other team there so this
is actually probably gonna triple
without her doing anything especially
she can just click all the troops it
doesn't matter yeah well she attacks
she's attacking a town hall uh 12 at the
town of 14 so her troops massively out
leveled And to clarify 14's the highest
level Town Hall you can get 15 is the
highest 15. but every time that level
there's a big power jump but why are you
even able to ladder against is it like
what's the range could you ladder as a
town hall level 14 to get to town hall
level three you can only go two up or
two down in two down you're just blessed
God you're down you're getting really
lucky but generally because it's a it's
not like the trophies don't really
matter that much on the ladder does your
losers salute and people who are
attacking down unless somebody lower end
up getting a massive Loop penalty so
they usually are incentivized to not do
that during normal play I see yeah
is there a loser's queue where you only
rolled Town Halls higher than you when
you start to get to a higher and higher
trophy level then you're gonna more
often encounter somebody that's higher
than you yeah it's like why I don't play
chess anymore because I got so good that
the games just weren't fun anymore yeah
that basically what he said that's
that's what happened to me too yeah
that's why most people like to like the
the latter is more about just farming
Loot and just trying to just mindlessly
play the game a little bit there usually
when you get it the real PVP happens
when you get into the war and then you
always have an even match up where
you're where you're playing with your
teammates and you're all playing
together and that's where the the that's
where all the competitive plays letters
like whoa whoa whoa whoa this bass looks
crazy
no no no this is terrible he didn't
break an army at all all he has here is
only the four Heroes and uh a Siege
machine I guess there he didn't even he
didn't actually train an army there he
has no Army he only has his Heroes what
town hall level does he have well he's
going he's 14 he's attacking the 13 but
it's going to be very difficult to get
the town hall down without any troops I
mean did his brain just fail to
communicate who's his brain here you
know what his brain is a bit the same
since chest boxing bro is this
embarrassing your fault iman's brain has
not been the same since yeah don't put
that on me I think it's a start tag if
anything
yeah that's a that's a big mistake right
there I mean he's gonna zero start this
that's gonna be zero that might be a
thing
that is a huge throw because everyone
else seems to be sweeping by just
spamming troops at least getting one or
two stars uh and and Amman Hamilton for
I will blame sir tag on this one you
keep barbarian barbarian team Barbarian
taking a hit Danny you nervous over
there wait which team were you again I'm
team King buddy all right and it seems
like team Barbarian take a little bit of
a hit I want to name it I want to name
it ludwig.com it's still Services chess
we just changed the name
how about this drop the chest
just just.com it's cleaner like the
beta's greatest contribution ever drop
the the drop the the okay well for
everyone watching at home by the way
this is one of six rounds that will
pre-face the final Challenge Clash
Royale is up next which is a format that
many of you will have played uh that
some Danny feels comfortable about we
are starting here in the ladder and how
do we feel about this one this one also
seems like a wash I'm looking at a tiny
little base and I'm looking at a bunch
of troops that haven't been used yet
well he's got a little bit of a problem
there see that big build Oh no just
kidding it went down the town hall was
almost out of the base there almost
didn't go down at all and that would
have converted all the way to a one star
there if he didn't get it but he's got
so many troops here once again we're
seeing uh a dip down where our Channel
14 ended up getting matched against uh
channel 13. so they must be at a
relatively low trophy count here as they
play through and that's definitely given
the advantage to the attacker yeah I
think that's the theme we're seeing what
is this
this is what we call a progress base I
don't know if you saw that right there
yeah can we go back to Gotham chess what
was that yeah got them chests on a
problem
yeah there was uh there was a progress
base there which is where people just
like line up all the buildings to like
track their upgrades not actually defend
anything and so they just stacked
everything into like nice convenient
piles is there a need what if you're
like a no loads refused base that lets
anyone take you is that fine
um do you have to set it up to defend
like basically you don't necessarily
have to you can you can just give away
the loot if you just I just want to step
away and you can you can get restart
every single time and you'll you'll just
accumulate loose a little bit what's the
purpose of that is that sandbagging
you're trying to lose like people who do
that in chess we call them sandbagging
um just because
May or maybe they just don't they're not
like stockpiling a lot of loot there
it's like they don't really if some
people will specifically do that to try
to give up the three stars so that they
end up lowering themselves in Trophy
over time sandbags and so that they can
just play at a lower rating and
sometimes there's better
handbags yeah it exists in everything we
call that cheating in chess there's
other types of cheating you may have
followed some scandals this year but
that's a that is a type of cheating you
can't do that you know what else is a
cheat code having Robert hessen ears
and
this is this is gonna be another easy
one right here Danny is it cheating if
I'm playing chess and then on like a
different computer I'm like putting in
the moves just to see like what the
rating would be that yeah that's that's
cool I don't do it I'm just wondering
yeah all right virtual is maybe the best
mid gamer because he does chess and this
is how's he looking Eric well the play
is terrible okay but he also got a lucky
draw again and got a lower base there so
he he should be okay here it feels like
you're impressed by no one but
specifically unimpressed by Sir tagum on
Hamilton who maybe we should go back how
did you say that's terrible I'm seeing
pink and blue dragons destroying Town
Hall this looks amazing to me there were
definitely some little players here but
that base so the way the Electric
Dragons work is when they strike a
Target they shoot a chain lightning so
if the targets that they're hitting are
close to other targets they'll chain
through them and hit lots of buildings
so you should use them early and you're
not even thinking about how he's
funneling I'm sorry Danny is so slow on
this stuff yeah they didn't need to
funnel on a lot of these here because
the like the these bases ended up being
so low level they got lucky with it as
long as they actually brought an army
that is so like that that's a good start
but uh these bases are relatively low so
they're not really having too much of a
struggle now this one's kind of weird I
said you can only go too down but
somehow they ended up going three down
and they're attacking a town hall 11. so
uh yeah this this is gonna be a three
star like effortless how do your
eyeballs see the town hall level so fast
yeah because there's uh there's the main
building that was in the middle of this
base here it was a big white building
and it that's the town hall it's out
there so you can you just know what it
looks like the town hall
you usually have eyes like that yeah
no you watch it every day like me and
you just kind of learn it you know
apparently it would be really
embarrassing if I didn't know that you
know
so it seems to me unless we can take a
look over at Amman answer tag that
everybody that we've seen at least has
been crushing three stars no problem
and everyone's supposed to go a total of
two time
which means
besides them on yes that almost
assuredly teams barbarians should lose
damn it yeah like we're only seeing
three stars true and we have the results
screen here it's not updated yet but
this is the result this is what it
you'll it'll look like when it is
updated so I'm seeing the trophy levels
that they're playing at right now uh
they're playing I see that account uh
that I that was just on screen it was at
uh like 1900 trophies which is really
really low that's where I would expect a
player if they're just kind of falling
into the natural progression of things
that's where about uh Town Hall 9 or 10
would be and they're tunnel 14 which is
like that means they're okay to play
basically they're they're playing
against people who purposely end up
dropping their trophies down to that
level to be able to try to get more Loot
and attack uh under level players like
you're saying they're like with it
don't help me when you go into the war
mode of the game there but in farming it
can be a little bit advantageous this
one a little better this bass seems to
be getting thrashed this is a progress
base this is what I was talking about
earlier with the progress base where you
can see where all the buildings are just
kind of lined up by their type or
they're just using it to track the
progress usually people don't set this
as their active base and they just kind
of or some they'll look at it when
they're like trying to choose what
upgrade they want and then they'll
sometimes log out and forget that they
had that set and then they'll have it
set as a defensive base so it's
organization Plants versus Zombies yeah
it's just like mowed them down like
lining them up to just be mode they're
just slowly walking through it's another
three star look I think we can safely
say and maybe I'm wrong about this maybe
this score will blow my mind but that
zero star was a lethal blow for Danny's
ownership of chess.com and potentially
his entire like relax here Danny come on
yeah hold it together it's only
challenge number two property all right
that's my property buddy I'll charge you
for that we charge for paper we love the
environment so
uh I believe we should be I mean I feel
like they're crushing through more than
two games say that one more time
ah we're waiting for the scoreboard to
update
uh it'll be really cool is if that chest
opened and there was something in there
for for us there is there is something
in there at the end oh here it is
two stars on the screen actually Iman
himself and the star he got that's what
I say see I'm a positive team leader
that's when my team wins but I wonder if
he learned his lesson after going in
with no Army on the first one to
actually make an army for the second one
there I didn't see what the second
attack was
um yeah I'm sure that he learned and
he'd actually tell you a lot about
funneling now wow impressive man there
was no funneling there was no funneling
in any of those attacks you don't have
the same vision as a man he funnels
amazingly he's a funneler he's that's
what they called him in high school
funds a lot so that's challenge two
we'll wait for the scoreboard I'm
guessing this is a team King win if that
is the case that means they get four
additional minutes as it stands now for
the final challenge which is going to be
the Clash of Clans raid challenge which
should be very similar to what we just
watched
yes the only difference being it's not
about uh just winning in the three
minute time period it's about doing as
many different runs as you can so
there's advantage to playing well
because you'll get in and out faster all
right but okay I've been doing the math
here and my team still has a chance all
right if we win Clash Royale next I will
take my team up against your team in
puzzle rush and spell chess no yes no I
mean I think team Barbarian oh yes
wow I don't know what happened but Rey
Enigma might have been the worst Clash
player to ever do it
they got a total of zero points but it
wasn't a big enough throw for team King
wow uh to be out which means team
Barbarian does take the L still
uh and team King as we predicted is up
two challenges you can see right there
what's the advantage plus four minutes I
thought you were giving me good news
there now it was good news we had the
worst player in the entire competition
yeah it just happens that them being
that bad wasn't enough okay but that's
that's plus four minutes for the whole
team not just like specific players so
that's good that's gonna expand to the
whole the whole team gets four and
they're gonna get a huge Advantage out
of that so that makes every single
challenge that much more impactful right
because four minutes in the hands of OJ
is a lot more valuable than four minutes
in the hands of every other chess player
combined exactly yeah that that is okay
so but if we win Clash Royale
we are the favorites in puzzle rush and
spell chess I'm calling it what so this
next one
what is Clash Royale Danny you're the
expert here so I do play a lot of clash
Royale on my phone and
it's you know it's it's a very quick
game it doesn't involve all the stuff
there's no funneling involved you just
Place pieces and they attack it's
glorious it's glorious and that's it you
don't have to do anything Clash Royale
is easy but you do have unless you play
you burn Elixir which is slowly
regenerating resources so if you if you
start to just throw everything down and
you start to get it in Elixir deficit is
what you call it where you have one
player who's managing The Elixir a lot
better than the other then you can
definitely slip ahead so it's very very
very skill based but uh as opposed to
The Clash of Clans where they're just
attacking a random person on their
version of ladder which is kind of non
it's not competitive the latter or the
attacks here are going to be a lot more
close I think because you're actively
playing against a defending player who's
going to be at the same level as you are
okay so you're playing against the
person who's the same level you are each
duo will play three games against a Duo
from another team so this is a PVP they
don't get to find something they're
playing for each other they're playing
against each other that makes me I don't
gotta find someone who's three ranks
lower and click a bunch of buttons and
all of a sudden Levy looks good matches
will be played in a 2v2 double Elixir
draft mode
which kinda sounds like a good Friday
night but doesn't make a lot of sense
what is it 2v2 double Elixir drop that's
what you're saying I got this no he's
got it you got it Elixir doubles in this
mode so normally there's a certain
amount of time to go from 0 to 10 elixir
it's it's double so it's faster it's a
faster game and draft mode is designed
to level the playing field a little bit
because pros at this level they've got
all their cars that they're really good
at so draft mode means that it's a
little more random like they have to
draft the cards that are available to
them so they may not be playing with
cards that are there like specialty
cards Eric how did I do that's pretty
good uh follow-up question for you 2v2
it's built into the game yeah 2v2 is
built into the game there so basically
what they're gonna have is they'll have
uh they're gonna have a Four Towers
instead of three so you'll have normally
you have your king Tower and you have
two princess towers and then in 2v2 mode
you're gonna have two King Towers which
are your back line and they they start
off like unactivating they don't fight
back unless somebody does deals damage
to them so it can be if they mess up and
they can get them both activated they
can put out a lot more defensive
pressure sure so let me explain in 2v2
the push really matters what's a push
you might ask in Clash Royale the push
is like you can't just be impatient with
your with your dudes and your Elixir
because then they die one at a time it's
a lot like developing all your pieces
why don't I just Spam it all at the same
time so they all walk together that's
what so the push is you you patiently do
your Elixir so then you basically get
everybody at once going like two armies
and that allows you to like just win the
game what do you mean do my elixirs how
about doing it so if Visa starts
dropping everything that he has and just
putting some giant wave of things going
through if they do what you call a
counter push and they are able to
actually defend against that and use
what they have on defense then if they
wipe everything out there with the
assistance of their defensive towers as
well then they could have a whole bunch
of troops Still Standing when the dust
settles and with the with their opponent
now exhausted from Elixir they can have
a good counter push there and elixir is
what determines how quickly you can
shove out troops how do you recharge
Elixir it just naturally goes it's
automatically refilling but but as he
was saying if you burn through with a
superficial attack they not only defend
but now everything comes back and when
they get to that halfway mark you'll see
it they drop a bunch more with all the
Elixir they gain and the push just kills
you this reminds me of a rally car race
that I watched on YouTube the other day
it was this 51 year old Japanese racer
and he didn't he didn't re-up gas he
thought I'll just make it to the end in
first by a long shot gets to the end
line 100 meters away car runs out of gas
gets out of the car and starts pushing
the dang the vehicle no because he could
not push a car 100 meters faster than
another car could catch up and drive it
was actually depressing because the car
was sludging up the hill I don't even
think he continued pushing he gave up
but that seems to me similar to to this
counter push where he shoved out
everything he had wasn't enough and then
uh oh you have zero Elixir now and they
have troops still up and now they're
catching up to you yeah I think a lot of
the the most inexperienced players are
gonna like the biggest problem you're
gonna have is you over commit to uh into
a defense or an offense and you end up
getting counted really hard so if you if
you do push really heavy and you end up
having them do a good counter attack
there then you're just kind of you're
just kind of really screwed by portable
Elixir I feel like it's gonna be a lot
more forgiving because you have two
players and it's a double Elixir then
you're going to be able to regenerate
your resources fast enough are you
regenerating it separately or is it you
pull from the same Elixir you can
generate separately and and it's
actually funny because when I first got
into classroom I was because my kids
were playing my two boys and they're
older now but they still play some but
we that's all we did was 2v2 and I feel
like the bad 2b2 players basically play
like too many one-on-one games the good
2v2 players really coordinate it well
and and everything comes at you at once
so it'll be interesting to see whether
people are communicating like you know
you have to talk to your teammate and be
like hey like save your Elixir like let
them you know you have to do all that
stuff well just like in uh chess if you
they're like chess obviously only has a
couple of different pieces and you just
gotta figure out what they do but in
Clash around now you have a lot more
options of different uh cards and so
knowing what they all do and the
experience of knowing what every single
car does is gonna definitely give you a
big Advantage but even if the the
players are coming in with a little bit
of unfamiliarity especially when they're
playing a draft where they don't know
exactly what they're going to end up
with then the the teams that have
somebody who can coach them at the same
time is going to definitely help out a
lot I think okay I have a question
because we are doing Clash here
each Duo is going to be able to play
each Duo I believe it's a round robin oh
is that correct each Duo plays three
games against Duo from the other team
yes so I believe it's around Robin well
oh you're right yeah I got a full round
robin is it because well if a team on
team barbarian was to play every team
from Team King you would play Four true
ah so they're playing against the same
team three times so they basically are
playing a best of three okay here we go
okay oh
yes not a not okay so it's not it's
never a best of three and then because
you count up all the team wins yeah okay
sure understood copy and this is not
Stars this is just win or lose
that's it Eric by the way I did let that
that Flex you had passed where you said
in chess there's only a couple pieces
and then Clash Royale there's dozens of
cards I heard what you said I chose not
to respond
just letting you know I let that go
there's I mean to be fair two rows that
are just one piece that was kind of
unoriginal yeah yeah yeah they could
have done a little more duplicates after
that you know like literally half the
pieces are dupes
half of them are dupes you would be sad
chess will be here when every other game
is gone I'm not doing this right now
it's beauty is in its Simplicity though
where it can be so simple and so complex
at the same time
he's a poet and he knows it I know I'm
pretty impressive well let's take a look
here it seems like they're just making
sure that that their their stuff's
already how does the draft work it's
like a set pool that both teams are
choosing from and is it snake draft is
that it uh not a snake but you get given
a certain list of random cards team one
chooses then team two gets to choose and
so you see the cards come off the board
as they choose them guys we're seeing
this right now actually on the screen
here is this the draft format or have
they already drafted away
okay game is happening yep in a kremling
and Ash versus this is so much one OJ
you said OJ is pretty dang good OJ and
Ash are both clash Royale YouTubers they
both have uh they've built them playing
since the game came out so like you're
you're looking at very seasoned season
players here and so they can definitely
coach their team uh we're seeing some
attack on the left Tower there but it
looks like you just put in a minor
underground they're just trying like
sometimes they just kind of
we'll test the waters at the very start
there just kind of throw something down
so they don't waste Elixir while waiting
for the team to respond but it's going
to be end up it's gonna end up being
very very fast paced with a lot of
different troops coming down at the same
time yeah you don't want to have 10
elixir right that's a failure because
then it's not recharging not necessarily
sometimes if your opponent you want to
play and see what your opponent does
first if you're both sitting in attend
Elixir waiting for the team to make a
move then you may be able to take
advantage of it yeah okay
there's actually a stat for it they they
can show you afterwards how much elixir
you wasted which is how much you sat at
10 and weren't using it
um
okay so that was kind of interesting you
saw that big rocket cross the screen
there yeah notice how the rocket was
specifically positioned to not activate
the king Towers behind the king Towers
behind are not actually dealing any
damage to everything up forward right
now so as long as they can uh not deal
damage to them they'll stay out of the
fight there until the princess Towers go
down in front of them but team Ash is
killing if you look at the corner the
corner the right corner Tower it's only
got 337 strength left and it's because
of that that you know Cannonball Cannon
they have that's just like you plant it
and it just kills the tower unless you
deal with it no where'd you see the HP
are you seeing that the HP is on the
tower itself there so you're looking oh
yeah you guys are crazy 337 life on that
uh right side Tower right now and most
of the other towers are mostly full
except for that top left one and so now
the black just had to play it or not
black red just had to play it in a
defensive position that little that
little um Cannonball thing got destroyed
so blue is back on the grind here
pushing a little bit well red is
countering pretty are pretty well right
now they got a lot of forces built up
there airplane defense now so you get
that giant skeleton come to the right
side if that skeleton reaches the tower
it'll start to hit it but then it'll
actually blow up and destroy the tower
when it goes down so I think there's a
little more down
yeah but the left side
big man on the campus ah too far for the
king Tower this is well he got the tower
down on the right side but that left
side actually defended they were
throwing like balloons down on defense
which is a really really bad move but
they really don't actually attack
anything they just go to the tower this
is it right here will the rocket have
enough There's 7 40 something left there
not enough okay watch the timer here
because the timer runs out there and one
person has a tower down and the other
team doesn't then the team that has all
their Tower standing winning so he's
gonna hold for 13 seconds okay they're
going to overtime now so they're
definitely holding holding strong here
now the timer is gonna restart and
they're gonna have
uh they're gonna have a tower down on
both sides here so now as we go into
overtime the next Tower to go down
Red's got 2400 in the top right Blue's
got I think that's like 1600 in the
lower left if the monitor that's far
away
is not deceiving my eyes
yeah and that's HP that that's tallying
yeah well so what I'm seeing right now
is uh all the king towers are activated
so we're actually doing a lot more
defensive uh damage right now so you can
just see that Anna just doesn't know she
was sitting at 10 there she didn't I
mean so her cards I wasn't even gonna
get up and show you lud because this is
going to be great I'm just gonna
everyone just you yeah you get you get
your country tush you up there
probably with Elixir and she didn't know
what to choose and that was killer well
when you start to have so much elixir
come in so fast then you're playing more
rapid fire and so you may be like
overwhelmed by having too many options
and it's something wait right look at OJ
he pulled off a direct assault on the
double King Towers but that's a hugely
it's a hugely risky play because if you
don't kill the king Towers your Tower is
way more likely to get killed there in
the front but it's paying off all right
Bluetooth there we go easy
they're just continuously pressed on
that left side there until they took it
did red team do nothing there they were
trying to fight back but there was too
much coming at him they couldn't deal
with it as they as it was arriving wow
okay Inferno Dragon won it for for OJ
and blue there it got out of controls
The Inferno Dragon deals a straight
laser of Heat versus a fireball and as
it goes the damage like multiplies on
itself so The Inferno Dragon got out of
control and killed the king Towers yeah
if you let that lock onto a tower and
give it time to build up there infernos
are very very dangerous for uh for just
destroying buildings if they get any
time to work because Eric do you
consider me dangerous no you work you
wore pink Crocs today
they were still purple's a color of
danger Ludwig comes in wearing pink
Crocs and it's hard purple it's hard to
take a man seriously when he's trolls
threatening
but put the camera on the crop it's
threatening lilac
oh yeah I'll see you after this no
comment yeah what is this view we're
seeing a different view here this is
this is uh like a spectator mode yeah oh
sweet okay we can see a lot more on this
yeah
now we can see both sides but who's
playing who I don't okay there it is
sapnap and sap Daddy and Gotham are blue
botez
means uh like cards you can play like I
speak French I don't like to bring it up
okay but
so I'm not seeing I see a lot of uh
troop cards on to the uh on Blues team
here but I don't see anything that can
like hit a lot of troops at the same
time like a fireball or a rocket or
arrows or anything like that so there's
a big push coming at The Blue Team I
think they would have uh they'd struggle
to hold it back a little bit there if
they don't have like a big spell they
can drop it but they're but their troops
are killing it look they're already
taking down the tower they've got hot
they've got the uh they're crushing the
wild hogs they've got the uh the
Barbarian crew do you have wild hogs in
your deck
well they if they can just maintain the
offense there they should be they should
be okay here but we're seeing a little
bit of a counterfeit wild hogs by the
way I didn't I don't know if you were
asking me I was asking you about your
Hogs yeah I'm I'm not a wild hogger I am
a hog rider
[Music]
yeah how does the king Tower get
activated if it deals if it's dealt
damage it'll activate or if the princess
Tower in front of the king Tower goes
down then the king Tower activates okay
so that pink ugly Goblin going up the
screen that's called Elixir Goblin it's
honestly the dumbest card in the game I
don't know why anyone uses it Elixir
Golem I mean yeah the Elixir Golem
because as it dies those little bubbles
are giving the enemy team Elixir and I
think it's the stupidest card and I love
when people play it
because you like getting Elixir I love
getting Elixir look I just got one watch
I'm gonna kill I just got another half
Elixir if I'm blue and I'm seeing that
the blue team's about to take down this
second Queen Tower and it looks like
their towers are just Juiced up how is
your team so freaking jacked on every
single game I think it's like Synergy
positivity like I think these are things
we focus on you focus on like you're
like kind of a tough guy like kind of a
hard ass you know I like I like letting
them be the boss wait there's gonna go
OT no no it's not because
yeah you guys bring up points that I
didn't think about yeah I didn't think
that they were yeah less crowns well
look at I don't know if you noticed but
uh blue actually had like full health on
all their towers at the end of that and
both of the princess towers for red were
about to go down so well we're back
watching a team that we saw play a bit
earlier OJ in Virtual against Ash and
Anna krambling it was a close game up
until
OT is there a universe that Ash and Anna
kremling are able to take a win was it
that close or do you think that OJ and
virtual are just going to crush I think
they came per they played pretty decent
last time there I think uh this is this
was a little bit uh even in my opinion
what do you change like okay
um Let Me Be Anna kramling and you Ash
from all it's role play yeah look at
this big group on the left side here I
think he actually might get the king
tower out of this might be over very
very quick look at all the damage going
in here
of a push that is the definition of a
push that's how OJ won the first what
was Anna supposed to do that was so much
worse like what is she supposed to
change well in the position like I say
in the last game there although they
ended up having arrows in the last one
that was hidden um but in a situation we
have a massive massive push like that
dropping troops just feeds into the push
that's already going because you don't
have enough uh defensive power but if
you could drop like a fireball or
something called it so they lack spelled
the troop cards are like the the ones
that move up but a spell is a big damage
and once spot Fireball rocket or arrows
and you called it they lack spell cards
so when a push is getting out of control
and you can't do you know you can't do
multiple damage that's the kind of stuff
that happens I don't want to watch them
again producers I feel too bad I would
like to take a look at if it's possible
a game from someone who has impressed
everybody here so far christinini who is
going up against I'm not sure who let's
take a look
if they are currently in a game I might
have jumped the gun there now that one
that was kind of interesting because I
don't think I don't to my knowledge
neither of them have a lot of clash
Royale experience so it just could be uh
the wild west out there as they're just
kind of but who's your teammates I'm
hoping that it goes through yeah so
that's that's the teammate that's a team
that is probably really big underdogs in
any Clash Royale I think this might be
good for my team Barbarian this could be
a good moment for our team Let's go Team
yeah
go get him let's keep an eye on them
which team do you want to be on I mean I
mean I want to be a partial owner of
chess.com so like I feel like I should
go with Team Ludwig here if you if you
join me I'll make you the CCO I
appreciate that the chief chess officer
the the chief Clash officer okay you
guys are already changing our time we're
already kind of in sync on that one the
chest flash officer yeah that works
there we go yeah easy uh
do we have a game to pull up here and
remember it is by which team wins the
most games yeah so I don't think based
off that reading and I could be wrong it
matters how much you win by
yeah so it's win or loss it doesn't
matter if they if they won on like a
overtime no Tower is destroyed and they
just went on damage dealt or they end up
getting uh I guess three Crown there
yeah which is when you destroy the king
Tower so like it doesn't it doesn't
really matter which way you win it you
just gotta win it yep it also doesn't
matter if you take best of three to win
it as long as you win the match I think
you get the points yeah and then even if
you only win one of three and it's the
third game that still helps we can see
all of our our players chatting away in
their little group okay we've got a
match right here we can take a look at
adorable
I see it's
the good folks
we're waiting for one to pull up
by the way this format
seems like you would have the quickest
turnaround in figuring out what to do if
you're just being Guided by someone or
is it too much brain power for your
better teammate to tell you like hey
start spamming troops I think if the if
if the more experienced player is
guiding them they can they can at least
tell them like hold hold or just try to
defend that like try to they'll just get
like small commands and then they could
tell them when you're going for a big
push and like we try to push hard on no
I mean I think we saw OJ do that right
there yeah all right we got a match here
clearly we've got Levy but yeah I think
OJ was literally just guiding them to a
victory
let me let the good people see what
Levy's doing right now he's
this is Levy's 1p view this is not
Observer mode and he's he's got Electro
Dragon over there on the right that's
not gonna hold back everybody that's
adorable oh there's a strong push going
to the right side and right now blue has
no Elixir so there's not really a lot of
they can do nope they're able to defend
it all right well so they held back and
they got arrows they're able to wipe out
everything on the right side and now
they start a they're pushing on both
sides right now which is kind of
interesting attacking both sides at the
same time it can be a little bit
challenging but it forces the defender
to defend on both sides at the same time
so it's not always a bad idea
yeah I like that uh Inferno Tower to
distract a lot of things because when
you drop a tower or a defensive
structure then it causes the the troops
that are going that way especially ones
that only target but look at that
well-timed rage dude on the lower left
they drop rage on Inferno dragon and he
gets out of control and just kills the
tower in three seconds like rage is a
boost of uh how quickly you can do stuff
and Inferno Dragon plus rage is lethal
what the crown do
he picked up a crown
well red picked up the crown right now
yeah yeah that that's what it is right
there on that push with The Inferno
Dragon yep is a big deal did he get it
did he actually have a rage spell there
he did no he dropped rage and that's why
that's why it went so fast okay I wasn't
sure if he had a troop that dropped the
rage instead
um but Oh you mean like a lumberjet I
didn't see that but yeah it was
um okay but blue is getting it together
here it's a bit of a tight game yeah hog
rider making it all but this is I think
Eric called it well that they're they're
splitting their attacks and that's a
problem someone someone with less
experience is wasting hog rider on the
left while you've got a big push on the
right but that might be okay because the
hog rider is a is good solo as long as
nothing goes into defend it so it can
get a little damage there but they're
splitting the damage on the towers right
now and they're running out of time
right now so they got 20 seconds to
destroy a tower on that red side now is
he gonna make it one hits one hit and
it's over time okay
holy
oh wait can he cycle through his deck
here and get him he's got a cycle fast
he doesn't have a spell to him
no he's not okay Blue's going down they
couldn't get the push fast forward
through that was awesome actually that
was nerve-wracking doesn't know anything
else to take from Levy Rosman
and we're switching over directly to a
spectator mode game here and I believe
this is Sir tag and chess bra against
zocus and array enigma
yep here goes the Elixir and so you'll
see that initially until they actually
play the card there you see everything
is covered in the question marks there
so until they actually start playing
things you don't know what they have so
sometimes people will hold uh like a win
condition card or something they can hit
really really hard and try to surprise
them if they don't know the what is
actually coming at them and they're not
ready to counter with whatever they have
so here goes hog rider so that big guy
on the left is Pekka he didn't make it
across the 50-yard line but if he does
as part of a push red will have a huge
Advantage but look at that Elite
Barbarian dude that was so fat wait
there's no defense on the right at all
yeah no they're not stopping it they're
just they're putting so you see red
trying to defend on the left side there
but that'll leave barbarians just
stepped in there and just look how much
damage is happening the kids call those
e-barbs it's like barbarians is there a
difference in where you can push your
troop like is Rey in charge of the left
side or can they can drop so each player
can drop on their side of the bridge
there uh anywhere on their own side of
the bridge uh until a defensive Tower is
dropped so as soon as that when that
left side Tower dropped and the right
side now they can deploy on their side
of the bridge so as soon as you start to
get some deep damage then you can have
your deployment Zone extended I think
we're about to see our four nil Tower
our first four nil Tower dub look at
that Four Towers to nil that was the
most dominant victory for any player so
far thank God for my team that was Sir
tagging them on Hamilton let's go that
was ugly hold your attack was going to
be a big player there on the on the
Clash Royale side of things there when
you're playing against uh two people or
not Clash Royale natives then you're
going to be a little bit as a
disadvantage so sir tag probably ran
that team and that that made it a pretty
easy uh easy fight for them I think I
can't tell if that sir tag swagging out
or Rey Enigma not being good
probably a mix a little bit of both
um a little column a little calmby well
we can take a look here at the
scoreboard and we see that it's a dead
tie right now I don't I don't believe
we've gone through all the games just
yet
uh but uh that seems oh that's all
that's it oh
that was a tie
wow okay so they decided not to play out
the third game I believe uh and to to
help speed through some things here uh
and that means it's four to four uh wins
so it's a tie what was the tie breaker
what means uh what that means is that
each team gets an extra minute so if we
take a look now it's five minutes of
additional time for Team King one minute
of additional time for Team Barbarian
the score is split four to four at the
end of clash Royale uh wow sweaty one I
feel a little robbed by the uh the
French voice of God here this is like if
God was French I I feel like my team was
just getting some momentum and you rip
Clash Royale away
I don't even know what you're saying
right now
you know what the french do no wrong
okay
that's just it all they have done is is
eat cheese
take two hour lunch break because that
sounds then walk 10 000 steps sure I
drink a lot of alcohol I'm pretty sure I
uh walked at least 10 000 steps the last
couple days here being in Paris and I
probably got some sunburn to show it
yeah so yeah like uh a little dangoo
with that Tan on a little vitamin D in
you never heard nobody uh what it means
is that team Barbarian does not make a
comeback but it also means that there's
still a chance because we didn't get
another lead there and we are only
halfway through our challenges we've
just reached the halfway mark we have
three challenges left two of them are
chess challenges uh and one of them is
another class challenge the chess
challenge come up next is puzzle Rush uh
which is something I like doing not the
actual puzzle rush I just like doing
puzzles this is where Amman Hamilton has
to shine he's the strongest player in
the field if Amman doesn't put up the
best puzzle Rush score
it's over for team Barbarian and I'm
gonna I'm gonna give another another
shout out to blitzstream Kevin bordee
also really needs to deliver here for
team Barbarian all right this is my
wheelhouse because I love puzzles
because all you do is instantly capture
with the queen and hope that it works
and some sacrificing move I heard that I
saw on Twitter that's what you do on
everything it was a great meme there's a
great meme from your social media guy
well soon to be my social media guy yeah
shout out to our social media team uh
I'm we're doing great killing it now I
don't know specifically how puzzle Rush
works is this just complete as many
puzzles if you fail when you're done
yeah so there's a time there's a timer
that ticks down so you're not just
trying to solve puzzles with Queen
sacrifices as lead says but you have to
solve the most puzzles puzzles possible
before the I think it's three minute
puzzle Rush we're doing
which means you have three minutes to
solve as many puzzles as possible yes
and then there's 15 minutes to get the
best score yes you keep re like running
that back yeah from what I see here you
only keep your best score so basically
we're looking at Peak puzzle Rush power
whoever puts up their best puzzle Rush
score
is going to win three minutes if they
start off with uh with a rough start
they are allowed to abandon the current
puzzle Rush that they're in and restart
that three minute timer and start it
over which is an interesting twist we've
never so we do a puzzles World
Championship every January and this is
an interesting format because this is
like a timer within the timer it's like
a game clock in the NFL and then a snap
clock right so you've got three minutes
to solve as many puzzles as you can but
if you're not happy with your flow just
get out of that one and start a new one
and why is that a good strategy because
the way puzzle Rush works is it starts
with easier puzzles and gets harder so
in order to put up a great score in
puzzle rush you have to have 25 puzzles
solved correctly with one minute left so
that's the magic marker for the best
players here so basically they need to
they need to just get into one game and
try to rush it all the way up into as as
quick as they can on the very first ones
and then they can take their time in the
last one exactly
if you don't have a score of 25 with a
minute left it's not a good rush for a
Time a player arguably even 30. like you
have to be you have to have that many
puzzles solved okay I feel like there's
almost no point as you can see the
screen's behind me and looking at The
Clash players because they are going to
drop scores of like five
you know within three minutes I feel
like if I was really rushing might get a
score of like 10 if I'm pushing it the
title players have an opportunity to
drop
10x what their counterparts will do yes
so maybe let's start by looking at Amon
Hamilton yeah in the puzzle rush we are
looking for the highest score and we are
adding up the highest score everyone
gets together yeah so it'll be all eight
people for team King all eight people
for team Barbarian whatever their
highest score is whatever their Peak is
added together whichever teams is higher
wins uh so let's let's pull it up right
now because I believe
that let's go if we can to Amon Hamilton
I can't imagine a world here here we've
got OJ you can already see he has nine
is his best background
okay backwards mate yup okay that's good
okay but you got to go fast
I can't think all right give me him on
Hamilton give him on this is too slow
for me as soon as we can we'll get
around Hamilton when I watch these on
when I see these on Twitter I spend like
15 minutes each puzzle so but to be fair
even though what love said is true the
title players are gonna win this because
all eight scores count in the end it's
gonna come down to your best scores
right so in a way it's almost like your
worst puzzle
is going up against the other puzzle
rusher if you make a wrong move there
does it tell you that you took the wrong
movement correct one it gives you an X
and you're also done it's GG right
uh you get three x's and you're out
three strikes so you should just be
taking some gambles then yeah here he's
taking way too long there you go yeah
he's got seven and this is OJ who's not
a chess player
he maybe he is doing pretty dang well
doing pretty good look at your whole
board man your whole board there's a
rook that can Checkmate the black
keyboard yeah where's the timer for the
individual chess rusher like it's got
that's his overall time yeah
my guess is we'll see it on someone
else's I think because you know everyone
we're following is doing their own
streams so he just doesn't really have a
crop right
um he has not seen this podcast first he
thinks some of the night yeah he didn't
see it this might be our first oh gets
there maybe we're are we staggering this
is that why we don't get a mon or Levy
or
um
because if we're staggering then that's
great I guess we're gonna we're gonna
get no shot or staggering it doesn't
make sense there you go that's a great
movie go let's go the killer score
he's always one voice check
we're already on 20. so this he is this
a great Rush right now this guy is on
Pace with 90 seconds left he's going to
be above 30. this is a potential 45
score and you're not going to see a lot
of 45 plus scores in in three minute
puzzle rush so the and you can see these
are multiple ones right this is no
longer like one move I mean he's doing
the moves incredibly fast too fast to
even maybe understand some of the the
decisions all their progressively
getting more and more difficult okay I
see yeah
but this is this is wild
for context I am not the best puzzle
rusher in history but my best three
minutes I think is 42 of all time like
oh we saw on Red X
and some of them is thinking others it
feels like pattern recognition yeah
because there's a lot of similar puzzles
yeah you just need to take the bishop
just Knight
oh man this is so tough yeah okay he
does see it it was 98 special but he
spent too long on it he slowed down a
lot yeah so this is what happens that's
why I said the magic number is if you he
was he was on a great Pace before that
Miss he had 30 in more than 30 solved
with 90 90 seconds left he was on a
great pace
he's still going to put up a plus 40
score
I want him to beat your best score ever
ooh two hexes okay okay this is what
sucks is once you get two x's now you're
going slow because you just got two in a
row he did just get you in a row but in
theory you're worried about getting that
third X right so he's at 41 and any move
wrong it's over there it is so basically
Danny's best ever yeah on his first
attempt he'll have many more attempts to
do it let's he will beat my switch over
to take a look at virtual I'm curious
how virtual is doing right now that's a
good call out because worshipable might
be one of those one of those swing
players right because he if he puts up
some good puzzle Rush that could be the
difference in in his team winning and so
many of the early ones are just back
rank yeah that was all I read one of the
first chess books ever read was the
Bobby Fischer one yeah uh Bobby Fischer
teaches chess all back ranks yep
uh or at least that's what it felt like
well man's worth like
three other players right now well yeah
that's the question right so like how
much is a mon worth and because bear in
mind virtual is considered the chess
player for his team yeah and that's for
my team team King yep there doesn't seem
to be equal holes on team Barbarian yeah
uh at least equivalent to that so so our
boy virtual has to get at least 25 here
to be really adding value to his team
uh do you think 25 is a doable score I
do not and you can see now the camera's
no longer blocking that Eric sorry to
cut you off here you can see the rating
of the puzzle underneath the check mark
and so he just said like a 500 rated
puzzle when it gets to 30s what is that
you can like it can depend the algorithm
is designed to still be random because
we try to mix in like chess some easy
moments with tough ones so it's not a
hundred percent certain and that is
another reason why puzzle Rush was so
fun is because there's some Randomness
to it if you do enough puzzle rushes you
will get an order of puzzles where you
have a chance to get a better record
right because you will just get easier
puzzles on that particular Rush
um yup he's doing good though that's a
classic one
I think virtual's top pause although I
don't see how much time is left on his
puzzle minute 30 half of his time is
gone he's currently at where are you
seeing that you can see it right below
him ah right below his thing okay uh and
he's currently kind of killing it
he's done quite a few puzzles here 13 so
far
you know see if this is this one I feel
like any of the multi-move ones like the
the players who are not like the chess
Pros are gonna just get a lot of x's and
just kind of get end up with a really
really low this is his first real tough
two mover he's had he had some obvious
humor but you have to play Queen F1 here
you have to sacrifice the queen and then
realize that when the bishop takes it up
it opens up your rook and it was
checkmate with the truck so he didn't
see it yeah I did see that yeah you
totally different one check made one
yeah good night then I can go back ah
tricked you oh no oh
yep okay
you gotta see Bishop okay he's done 16
16. 16 that's fifth biggest all-time now
let's switch over to somebody who I
think is doing poorly and not because
they are bad and we should make fun of
them but because this is not their main
game let's switch over to Sir tag he
didn't really get it maybe that carries
over maybe that's strategic mind is
gonna it's gonna carry him here so sir
tag and we we're cut off a bit here but
sir tag uh is not a chess player uh they
are on a team with him on Hamilton so
lucky for them their teammate got 42 so
their expectations are a lot lower here
but we are
not doing too bad actually let's see if
there's a decent yeah
there you go so the right order for
anyone watching and and I know this is
uh trying to trying to add education to
a show that is clearly not about
learning we are here to have a good I
want to know though okay it's the order
is checks captures and then what we what
we call Tempo moves if I'm teaching a
kid sometimes you call it Queen attacks
because Queen attacking a queen is the
most powerful Tempo move okay pause
you've got three three yeah that was not
ideal not ideal everything you just said
went completely over my head so in every
position let's do it as we go through
we'll see if you get better at puzzles
as we go all right the first thing you
do is look is there a check there's no
way to check the white king so the
second thing you look for is captures
and now he sees the bishop can take the
queen you should just do it so look for
checks if there are no good checks often
there's a Checkmate in one as Ludwig
said there's a lot of back ranks to
start the second thing is what is my
best so here's so if you look for checks
that would be the first thing you see
start with checks there's a check on the
board and it's just easy so that it gets
faster when you the order of Chess is in
a is in a hierarchy checks are first
captures of major pieces or second and
then what we call Tempo moves which is
the idea that you would attack something
that's undefended but if you just start
with that order checks captures Tempo
moves right now there's a Checkmate in
one which is Rook takes Knight check yep
and so you you have to you can no you
can't move on to anything else until you
consider all the forcing checks all
right let's switch over to Gotham chests
because we're about a little over
halfway through our time here
uh it seems like your Tag's not doing a
bad job
447.
look at that that's his number one all
time that's his best score of all time
well not just this week but all time he
just dropped his greatest score ever
there's no point in him continuing and
he's no he's effing pissed you see him
just dropping F on me he's mad because
he missed this one and and he's pissed
about the order it was 92 first and then
queen of six and he moved too fast
apparently well he's still got 47 which
is nothing to scoff at that's ridiculous
that's insane
uh I would love to see the rating of the
puzzles this camera's blocking it
impressive performance let's switch over
to maybe Anna kramling
and see how Anna
is doing she's at 32 which is good good
Pace but 47 is like rugby two
yeah but if you got uh at least that
offsets the one from uh from Amman and
so at least that's gonna balance it a
little bit there and so if you want
rookie what rookie what
Danny is feeling he loves this section I
love this stuff you just because you're
just feeling good about yourself it's
fun and it's it's easy to be armed peer
quarterback when you don't have the
pressure on you it's it's had to be
Knight F4 yeah it was the night captures
I saw that with my eyes good job yeah we
gotta check here check with the queen uh
you're gonna check on H7 King moves over
one then you're gonna check on uh
no Queen H7
35 is not bad so let's switch over to
keep rolling it maybe Alexandra botez
how's
Alexander's sisters do a lot of puzzle
Rush on their streams before they get
playing so Alexandra and Andrea are both
I'll just say as far as ranking their
chess skills and where they stack as far
as Peak puzzle Rush they're both better
puzzle rushers comparatively for their
rating like they're good at puzzle
rushing they do it a lot did you just
insult her while complimenting her no I
didn't what I'm saying is here's the
deal is she as good as I'm on Hamilton a
chess no no but she scores puzzle rushes
in ranges that are closer to him than
like you would think she should based on
how strong he is because he's a top
Grand Master he should get a better
score can I chime in for a moment here
yeah she just failed within 14. that was
just gamesmanship she knew it was a bad
Rush she resigned it okay she knows
she's capable of a big score so if she
already got a if she already got a
better score earlier and she knows she
has to be at that time it has to improve
it there's no point to continue a bad
game right yeah she's so she's on a roll
what's going on it froze oh a little
delay it happens now do they finish the
current game that they're in if the
timer expires uh probably right but
she's crushing it I'm telling you she
rushes a lot that's what I'm saying all
right well let's see here if she's able
to crack her score I will give her one
more chance for swapping povs
come on Alexandra okay nice yup yup yup
I mean this is seeming to be a good one
between H7 you know just got a really
fast pace yeah yup
that was it that was a whole puzzle yeah
so the reason the algorithm does that
sometimes it's sometimes there are some
puzzles that are better than others but
the reason is we don't let the puzzle
continue once there are multiple ways to
win ah so that because at that point
it's unfair to the Russia is it supposed
to be the only winning move it has to be
the only winning move or the puzzle's
over so once there's multiple wins wow
what is going on yeah once there's
multiple wins then then the puzzle's
over a hell of a run right here yeah
she's doing great
you can see how much more complex these
puzzles are getting but she's got the
potential for a 30 with about 90 seconds
left this is a this is like she was
keeping Pace with him on that's what I
was saying
that'd be very impressive this feels
like my uh old days on my old Windows 95
computer when I was like mine
Minesweeper and I'm just like click
click click everywhere at the same time
and I'm like like my my hands are moving
my brain processes it
this this is this is moving very fast
he's doing great
9h3 takes Bishop okay
puzzle and she killed it oh his Bishop
takes a 95 after that it's like an 80
move puzzle
some of these puzzles are too dang long
right it's actually that's the wrong
Bishop we're playing for white oh
she made it herself it was kimchi too oh
man she might not get 30 here four she
still got a minute
take and take the Knight take and take
the night oh she she burned out all
right let's swap povs for the final
minute here can we take a look at the
Frenchman if possible
uh Blitz stream
let's do that
the musketeer himself
who's on a run
a lot of time left a lot of time left at
about to tie with the score we just saw
from Alexandra which might not be the
peak score I don't know everyone's Peak
score but
yeah that's right it's everyone's feet
he doesn't see the queen see even he's
missing a retreating move there
um
he missed one early though so honestly
if it wasn't for the fact that time was
running out he probably would have
resigned and restarted because this is
not he's capable of a better rush than
this
and everyone you miss it's not just that
it gets you closer to three strikes but
it makes you slower because you're more
nervous so should he be dropping a 40
bomb yeah he's he's a 40 bomber yeah
what do you think I could drop
I dropped big dunkers
I think look if you if you if you got on
this a little bit like you could put up
a 20.
Eric should I take that disrespectfully
did you hear that the same way I did
like you should take a bet on it
you can put uh you can try to use the
thing is this chance to Winchester come
back I'd put a little money on that I
put a little money on that what is your
best you probably already know your best
spells on Rush is better I've never
played Paul's rush in my life it's
whatever I'm gonna look up your account
right now I've never played you can look
I've never played puzzle rush in my life
I think within an hour I would bust out
a 20.
40 wraps it up
uh not a bad score and I believe our
time is up so now we're just going to
spend a little moment tallying up
everyone's highest score
you had a lot of big scores on the team
Barbarian there we didn't get to see a
lot of Team King that one and I feel
like we saw a lot of big scores there
Levy screwed up my team because he
probably put up the best of all with 47.
but oh oh for okay I see by because of
his support because of that number one
all-time I think this has to be a win
for team Barbarian because we're looking
at like the pros the chess the chess
Gods here and they were all able to put
up a a low 40s or a high 30s and that's
14 Barbarian Amon Hamilton put up a 40
Anna put up a 30. uh botes put up a 30
and then we just saw a 40 from
blitzstream Team King on the other hand
although Gotham chess had 47 great score
virtual capped out at like 15.
no surprise at all and I called it to a
t by the way but count that number 15
off team King loses team first of all
did I not say that if my team won Clash
Royale we still had a chance because we
were going to win puzzle Russian spell
chess and now I'm even more pissed but
you guys didn't let them finish Clash
Royale because that was our chance
because we're gonna win spell chess and
this thing's going to overtime baby this
is getting a little heated it's now
three minutes of advantage for team
Barbarian five for King but the time
Advantage doesn't matter it's a time
difference and advantage that matters so
two extra minutes still for team King
the only way you make that up is by
winning a challenge in the next
challenge we're going back to clash
specifically Clash Royale because we're
doing Clash Royale
1v1 this is the game this is the game
the game this is the real way to play
Clash Royale is that what you're saying
yeah you hated playing two
I was playing 2v2 with my kids that was
the gateway drug that was how they got
me in and then they they stopped playing
Clash Royale and I kept playing so I
play I probably played more 1v1 Clash
Royale than a grown man should admit
yeah well let's take a look at the rules
here for this one uh chess players
compete against other chess uh players
in Clash players complete against other
Clash players so there's no there's no
Advantage here really we're supposed to
neutralize it a little bit by having the
Clash people play against Clash the
chess people play against chess players
uh and they're all doing 1v1s in Clash
Royale they're playing two games each
they're gonna play against the same
person uh the chess players will be in
triple draft mode and The Clash players
will be in mega draft mode and now I
need Eric to explain what that mean oh
excuse me actually game one is just as
chess players game two is just a clash
players
well I'm Not The Clash Royale expert
here I feel I feel like uh Danny's more
of an expert on that I I I play but I
play very casually well I play uh random
random attacks I do know this game but
I'm also just getting so excited over
here because I'm doing the math and
we're gonna win this round because you
guys got Christina knee over there like
she's not a clash player right you've
got you got a virtual I mean he's gonna
he's gonna lose to one of the chess
players in Clash like come on Hamilton I
think I think sir tag and Ash
the only problem is you guys got OJ OJ
looks like he's objectively the best
Clash rep okay I'm sorry sir tag and OJ
are gonna play against each other we
could actually take a look we can
actually take a look at the matchups on
this sheet here for our game one it's
going to be the chess players playing
triple draft what is Triple draft so
actually I've never played triple draft
yeah I don't I don't know I actually
don't know I've only I've only played
double Drive I don't know so that's
that's not a very people watching at
home triple draft is a game mode
yeah it is I assume that you draft I
like to chew I I like to choose my deck
and I have what I'm comfortable with and
I try to stick with it and I just like
to do random attacks on the yeah on the
base ladder but like when uh when it
goes into draft mode like and you don't
get to choose what you're super
comfortable with and uh as far as you
get out of my comfort I will admit
something even further which just makes
me I am the anti you just spilled water
everywhere good job
I will take the heat on this so the
supercell can be mad at me because I am
there I am the demo they hate I've been
playing Clash Royale now for two years
I've never paid for password I never
will okay I also don't play in the clan
wars and I know that that's like that's
like how we feel about people making
friends and getting involved in clubs
because when they do that they're way
more invested in the chess Community I
never played the clan wars and the
reason I'm telling the story is not just
so supercell can be mad at me but also
because it's why I don't know triple
draft and mega drop because a lot of
these variants exist in the clan wars I
don't play the clan wars because what
happens with the clan wars is when the
boats go at each other you have to
compete in a variant that you may not
otherwise be playing in because it
actually makes it a little more fun
because now you're not just playing with
the deck that you have stacked now I'm
saying this as a huge fan of the game so
don't be mad I'm just not your target
demo I'm not a 12 year old who's gonna
pay his way to be level 14. I don't give
a flying you you know what I do it to
pass time and because I'm I'm highly
stressed I've been in therapy for years
I need to pass my anxiety and Clash
Royale is therapy for me that's my demo
all right but I'm not gonna upgrade and
it's why I don't know anything about
these speakers draft and triple draft
well we don't know about the draft mode
but we do know who's who knows playing I
have to remove the label off my water
I'm not trying to support fresh water
okay in fact I'm against it as a whole
you didn't get it don't drink French
water Clash Royale triple draft our game
one is going to feature virtual versus
Iman Hamilton do we want to make a
prediction on that matchup
I think virtual Crush yeah
game two is Gotham chess versus
Alexandra I'll go botez you're gonna go
botez that's fair game three is uh
Maestro luison versus blitzstream I'll
take bloodstream okay and game four we
have Rey Enigma versus Anna and I would
recommend taking Anna Rey is the only
person who dropped a zero yeah are you
specifically choosing everybody that are
on team Barbarian so that you can no I
said that I thought virtual was the
favorite against someone and I will say
the one that I'm less confident about is
I I just had like a fleeting memory that
maybe maybe louisan actually plays Clash
I wonder if he and I bonded over that at
one point because
um we chat on chess.com slack so I I
could be wrong about that but otherwise
yeah I think I look at Team Barbarian
and I'm feeling pretty confident
in this game one could be a big
Advantage for your team because you
predicted
well I guess you predicted two and two
you predict no you predicted three
people winning from your team in only
virtual winning yeah for my team I did I
think you're right about that to be
honest
um but it looks like they're jumping
into the game everyone's getting booted
up rooted and booted uh and this will be
our
penultimate challenge our fifth
challenge
with the only other challenge being the
one I'm most excited about spell chess
yeah
and then we're gonna get into the final
showdown
first of all Yep this is kind of this is
kind of it's kind of sweaty if my team
wins this one it's GG yeah that's right
that's right I don't even think I need
to mince words because then we'd have
four minutes of advantage
even if we well I guess it'll only be
two minutes if we lost spell chess we'd
have two minutes of Advantage it's two
minutes of Advantage a big deal uh when
it's compounded over that many players
then potentially but if you're if you're
dealing with people who are more
experienced and can uh can get
everything on the field and get the tax
done faster they might be able to roll
through attacks much faster in Clash of
Clans for the final challenge so like if
we if we see people just moving slow and
don't know how to operate the game very
fast and they could slow them down there
by default I don't know I I could see it
I think I feel like the four minute
Advantage is gonna be the big kicker
there if they can get that far but I I
think two minute is recoverable okay
that makes me feel
I know you just kind of gave an answer
like when you asked a grand master like
to explain a pawn structure you didn't
make it that you didn't give us the
clear answer that us noobs wanted I I
think but in the end I heard you loud
and clear two minutes is overcomeable
that's what he said it's overcomeable oh
and we're in it our first match Gotham
chess
versus let's do it let's go is that okay
Enigma oh it looks like the matchups
have switched up a little bit I believe
that's Gotham chess versus Rey Enigma
yeah it looks like it uh that doesn't
make sense Alexa right now they are on
the same team so I don't know how it
would work
wait say it again
to get ready
a couple of kids couple of kids
well they waited 30 seconds to into the
match there to start dropping anything
so uh that's kind of odd they realize
that they were okay they canceled out
yeah they're playing each other
all right here's one here's one here's
one let's get into a real one we got a
real one here my bad it's a Louis Zone
versus Blitz stream yeah it looks like
they're not sure they're choosing their
cards why is one picking so much quicker
I think they got until the timer ends
you can take your time but Luis just
this actually is making me
I doubt might pick even more this is a
confident drafter Louis Son and so I I
had a feeling and now I'm gonna go I'm
gonna double down on it I I think Louis
song has played himself on Clash Royale
and that this might win for your damn
team it's really bad for you that's
right I think if somebody didn't if they
weren't super familiar with the game
then they would have done that they
would have they wouldn't know what
they're picking or or it could maybe
it's the other way there maybe he just
has no idea and he recognize he has no
idea and so he's just choosing randomly
quickly
uh I don't know that is true it is tough
it's like the French day
it means it means no one even says that
it means it means you never know you
don't you don't listen to the the
beautiful language all right we need to
see pieces dropped instantly is that
right you don't want to stay at Max you
can start to push now normally when we
drop like uh troops we try to go in the
right behind the king Tower because then
it uh yeah delay just a little bit
longer so you can build up a bigger push
yep uh but he went off to the side there
he's got the electric dragon on defense
there so looks like he should be able to
defend with that electric dragon and
then start to counter push there but we
see full elixir on to who is that
bloodstream that is
blue yeah they're just gonna trade a
couple pieces here back and forth here
but not really not not much is going to
happen at this point here as they are
countering everything that each other's
doing playing a bit defensive with a
Turret the more I see the more I see
Kevin drop the more I'm nervous that
this is uh-oh okay well that's actually
helpful whenever someone's wasting a
fireball on like a single person you
know it's usually a misplate and look
he's got Golem so this is this is
objectively the hardest
like character to kill it moves the
slowest but if it gets to the tower it's
going to be a tower for your
bloodstream's gone well look at the
Elixir onto on a blitz stream right now
he's got a lot of Elixir so he can build
up a big push behind the Golem yeah
right now you have time to recover some
Elixir when you drop it on the back line
and by the time it reaches the bridge
you start to reinforce it with more and
more and more and this is this is over
blitzstream is gonna kill luisons tower
that Golem has only just begun and
that's what I'm talking about get the
dub in terms of Barb you were right your
your gut was right I think you felt good
about Louisa's quick draft but a quick
draft doesn't necessarily mean a good
news
well he had Towers win he had a chance
to slow that down significantly but he
but he or luisan put the Fireball and
missed the witch with it yeah Fireball
on defense and he missed the thing he
was dealing the most damage okay isn't
that kind of embarrassing to miss and
spells are the riskiest cards to miss
with because if you place a character in
a slightly wrong position and they build
up as they go like if you miss with a
fireball you just wasted four Elixir and
it's and it's no good yeah I don't miss
air Coots hits the shot every time you
don't know that about me Danny yeah you
don't miss this seems oh is that a whiff
that hit uh that that did something we
call it Splash damage it did some Splash
damage because it hit you know made a
big splash when it hit more than one
piece and the area got hurt Tower's
going down yeah that Phoenix is doing a
lot of work
once the Phoenix goes down it picks
itself back up if the egg survives you
were right that Rey Enigma is so utterly
lost out there he has no idea
I knew this I knew this coming in okay
but he got a prince through it he's not
or Anna's not doing anything he thought
that Prince so the prince is probably
gonna count on the tower yeah and that
was a horrible delusion the balloon
where'd that balloon go and the balloon
goes right past the king Towers to get
shot down before objectively the worst
balloon placement I've ever seen no but
the blue still got the tower didn't it
did it still hit the tower there and
actually uh drop a bomb on it it did
break through but if he gets one more
Prince loose
build no she's I don't know why she
right now I feel like she should be
concentrating on right side Tower
because the king towers
and she's got that uh right side Tower
she's letting the Elixir build okay
watch the zappy here zappy if it charges
up they don't counter it it will like
one shot the tower here then I was
looking at cards and guess what Randy
doesn't have e-whiz is a great counter
zappy but now you're waiting
[Applause]
balloon doesn't fight the troops it only
goes after turrets in the towers oh my
God if she's gonna get that cow wait
wait
oh my God okay it's gonna go to it's
gonna go to just the king because the
bomb blows it up oh my God okay they're
tied
all right this this is the closest game
right here it's fascinating this is the
closest game but okay so what is that
what is that giant care practice in the
middle so no that that's the blue and
the blue bombs if it reaches the target
this is scary but now they can deploy
troops onto the other side of the board
there and they can they can deploy in
the other person's side of the board on
both sides literally gonna come down to
the wire but I think Ray Enigma is gonna
get it somehow yeah I I think you're
right I think you're right this is 1400
to 1300. come on okay she's got a rocket
right now if she hits the rocket and
gets a little damage on the tower he's
got the prince and she hasn't dealt with
that at all no okay they just went
around here stop that Prince got the
prince okay one two three
she might be able to pull it oh no no
not able to get it done
all right yeah there goes nice try I
don't even care about the team Anna
that's a ray Enigma win that's the only
person who I felt confident that wood
was going to lead us which means one win
for uh Ray Enigma one win for
blitzstream
against Maestro luison which is two wins
for team Barbarian so far yeah not good
if your team King fan which most of the
nation is
the most of the nation is but okay right
now I'm getting on it I'm gonna get on
it get off of it hop back off the time
there's a great nation of France loves
team King
oh man all right
it's gonna come down to weather there it
is anyone can handle OJ I need someone
on my team to handle OJ and get a dub
against that guy what it says 1-1 I
don't know how that mathematics works is
this is this the final
no it can't be it can't be yeah I feel
like there's more matches we haven't
seen this game too we must have missed a
game certain
sir we're missing game two okay and I
believe we're seeing it right now seeing
a live giraffe I'd love to get that on
screen because that's exciting to see
who they pick we can commentate all over
the bleep of that yeah give us a little
live draft action if you if you don't
mind see uh
wait a look at the format do they just
get one game yes so there's not there's
not like a best of three here no the
chess players get one game the pros get
one game and so far it seems
that the chess players on team King went
0-3
so I would need and here are the
matchups we have OJ versus sir tag
sapnap versus Roja and this is by the
way
this is just Christine yeah kristinini
versus Domingo yeah but no but Ray Ray
Enigma got you a dub man he beat
animated
oh yeah you're right yeah but that was
my team I missed that shout out Ray
I actually never doubted you for a
second I'm a rave fan of sorts
uh Domingo
christenini do we have an idea of who
wins this
meeting Domingo
based off the draft is someone doing
better
um not not a way to tell right now
unclear it's it's super unclear also
looks like they just have no idea who to
pick yeah it looks like they're is there
something you're shooting for for
average Elixir cost uh yeah usually
around you don't want to be over four
well too much yeah well you want to keep
it relatively low but you also need to
have like a win condition so like you
need to be able to have something that
can can that can actually build a push
and take a tower you can't have only one
Elixir unit and spam them if you don't
have something that can tank for a while
no because then uh then a single troop
from the other side there will be able
to take it out and the towers will
quickly clear one Elixir if you can stay
around 4.2 or under but have a good
winning condition you're in good space
now there is a big advantage to having
the low ones on your team and that you
can cycle through them quickly because
you only have four cards in hand but you
have eight cards total in your deck and
so if you have things that you can just
quickly dump to get to the cards that
are more important than just a little
bit of value but they can actually get
you to the cards that you actually want
to be able to take your win against
right it's a cycle deck it's almost like
a spread offense right I I know about a
cycle deck because I've played a good
amount of card games and like even
Kingdom Hearts back in the day it's like
a thing that you'd have to set up there
you go do you gentlemen mind if I leave
the dogs out by the way hey you're doing
great man you've got very well manicured
feed I don't want to just comment on it
but I'm just going to say don't so
that's weird I'm actually gonna put the
dog
okay
you don't want people people are weird
man they're gonna take a freeze frame
rate yeah when I when I own chess.com
this might affect your future employment
yeah you uh you got to be careful with
that with the feed picks I hear so well
we're about into it after a four hour
draft between these two competitors
they seem to be the weakest I agree of
the match-ups in our Clash Royale
section I don't know if that's fair to
the least confident drafters I would
agree with that at the very least yeah
and it's Domingo's side at the bottom
now I do I just noticed uh right at the
end there uh was it Christine Christine
Christina Nina picked up uh three months
guitars right at the very end there and
she's got a couple of giant where we saw
a lot of light troops there onto uh
Domingo's side I feel like that
Christine has the right to has a bigger
advantage in this one here christenini
will crush
uh if you can take it if she can use it
right though I was gonna say I don't
know but she she played Inferno Dragon
which was
I thought it was that Tower took a lot
of damage on the left side red yeah that
was not a good card against a witch
because Inferno dragon is powerful when
it gets damage on one target but it has
to deal with a lot of targets it's no
good but they okay they throw another
witch down there now which is very good
if you can uh pair it with something
that could actually deal a little bit
more damage because the skeletons will
provide tanking and distract the tower
there so like uh maybe a bowler to put
on the side there but she has to defend
on the right side because she's got that
uh that Prince coming at her and she's
got three there's a Three Musketeers
right behind and the Three Musketeers
doing an insane amount of damage they're
nine Elixir but they can wipe that Tower
they lock onto it and they're gonna take
it there we go but the other Tower Falls
at the same time on red and so we're
back to even yeah we're back to even the
uh the the hound dogs the fire dogs are
getting involved it's not a great
placement there of our uh lovely uh
um whatever it is not Ram yeah Ram Rider
little bro just sprinted on through this
guy fast yeah
so it's just it was five five elixir and
I didn't do anything it didn't find
anything all it did was just track The
Inferno Dragon they're waiting no one is
placing anything but this is smart
they're led to build up that was the now
you gotta go place your okay bowler is
an interesting move if you do witch and
RAM Rider together at some point that
could be nasty on the right side if
you're Domingo watch that Goblin giant
because the goblin giant gets reinforced
by Three Musketeer right now that'd be a
very very big deal but you can see that
they deployed extra troops there on the
other side of the board to try to
counter the goblin Giant and they're
able to stop it before it really got too
far it is going to reach the power maybe
a strike but they've done good job
they're just doing it all on offense the
witch is killing it on the right side no
defense on the right what
she just used some spell cards to get
rid of it
they're going to come out
Domingo loves that wish not GM oh but
the hog okay the Hogs are nutty the hog
is gonna be a tower who let the hogs out
it's gonna be over here that Tower is
gonna fall christinini crushed yeah
she's doing good she's doing really good
no no but look look at you guys still
defending pretty well here but that red
Tower is about to go down
the witch is working on it here the
witch is distracting him as long as it
could but not wasting Elixir place there
you go okay okay
I feel like uh Christini kristinini
needs to get the damage on the left side
Tower really really heavy right now and
yeah just kind of force him to play
defense there and just start driving
that heavy yeah because they're gonna go
to overtime here got two minutes over
time so overtime and that Tower is
looking tasty in the upper right corner
yeah you see Domingo pushing that right
side Tower hard if that Tower goes down
the poison it's getting it lower yeah
Poison's really good because it it hurts
the tower but at the same time it's also
clearing up the defensive troops in the
area as well and so is that it's going
to be a hit there we go
Barbarian alive
okay
I just switched to team King but I feel
like I need to jump there are a few fans
out there rooting for me I would love to
see
oh my God this is it this is
formerly the artist known as Ash of
clash drops yeah easy yeah of course Ash
is a very very very experienced player
has been loyal making Clash Royale
content since like the game came out so
that's another one for team Barbarian
did Sir tag versus OJ happen because I
was kind of looking forward to that one
that's the one I really want to watch
please tell me that did happen then this
is the worst day of my life tell me we
didn't miss sir tag versus OJ if we did
make him play again tell him he's like a
server
it happened and I'm gonna say right now
it happened it did yeah okay but it
looks like team barbs it's not close
it's taking it team Barbarian crushed so
it looks like sir tag actually won that
right yeah yeah certeg did win over OJ
yeah well that means that you win three
to five you called it all right back to
even uh thank you for saying that
because it's not just that we want three
to five it's that I called it I called
it an hour ago I said this was gonna
happen
you just did the you did the counter
push he was over here racking up points
there got two in a row five minutes to
one minute and now it's five minutes to
five minutes and we have the final
challenge I'm gonna give you some
confidence though you're gonna like this
all the pen holder of all the people in
chess category I believe Levy Rosman has
played the most spell chess
does that even matter now uh it's in one
of eight matches sends a lot of I feel
like a lot of Chess has to do with just
like familiar and scene patterns that
you've seen before but spell chess being
able to freeze part of the board there
and then also cast like a jump spell to
leap over other troops or other other
pieces I feel like it's gonna throw even
the the big Pro players for a loop in
that well let's go over what this game
is this is a brand new game available to
play on chess.com It's a combination of
Chess and Clash a new way to play chess
by adding some familiar moves from Clash
to chess
chess players are basically playing
normal chess straight up regular ass
chest
except for the fact that they each have
their own special ability that they can
use a certain amount of times I'll let
you explain more in depth though Danny
yeah so the two abilities we sort of
added from Clash that people would love
one is freeze freeze freeze is an area
of the board just like it would freeze
an area of the map and your opponent can
do nothing for a certain amount of time
so you can freeze a certain two by two
or three by three area of the game and
the other thing we added is Jump which I
guess you could relate to hog rider Ram
Rider or peace jumping across the lines
and going quickly you can jump over a
piece that you target so if you choose a
piece
you can jump over that piece for one
turn I could jump over you in real life
you actually probably could he explosive
over there A lot of that kinetic stuff
he's working on I can dunk
have you played it yet have you played
this I have so can you jump over and
directly capture the king you cannot you
cannot capture King you cannot you can't
check okay so you can't carry a check
and then immediately you need to check
but you can't like capture the king you
still have to Checkmate which means the
King has to be trapped okay yeah okay so
you yeah okay that's I like that I was
like I was a little worried I'm like
what did they just uh jump and then they
just jump over the troop that's blocking
the the king and just take it like I
mean I think just get it capturing the
king directly is better
super quickly though because of what
you're saying there's ways to lose games
very quickly because of these spells
that we've
to the game and I'm excited to see some
of the some of the big blunders here
it's going to be going to be epic well
this one's broken up in a similar way to
our previous challenge it's gonna be all
1v1s and it's going to be the chess
players playing the chess players and
The Clash players playing The Clash
players by the way your best puzzle
scorer survival is 26 so you have done
puzzle you had 26
um maybe your mom borrowed your account
was your was your bet that I couldn't do
more than 20. check it checking my phone
was that what you said survival mode
which is a different timer so I actually
think my instincts were pretty close if
you want to throw down the three minute
puzzle rush if we need a double or
nothing at some point I would like to
throw down bear naked wrestling but
first I would like to watch we have a
couple of matchups here that are really
funny that aren't going to be close like
virtual versus Amman Hamilton however I
I don't want to waste our view time on
that because we're all gonna be playing
at the same time if we're really going
to show off this game maybe we should
take a look at Gotham chess versus
blitzstream it's a great call because
these are two phenomenal chess players
who are playing a Now new game mode that
they don't fully understand and I
believe they're in it so let's switch
over to Gotham chess's POV I see him on
the big screen right now it's actually a
tiny screen but it'll become a big
screen
when Small Things become big
okay he's now on the big screen ready
for your viewing pleasure
and we have the alapin it's the English
opening
these changing board settings it's the
French you can't it's the French we're
in France it's the French I've had it
set up on my board all day the French
defense oh my shirt the French defense
is ear
oh wait was that just practice he was he
was just toying around a little bit he
gets a little crazy sometimes hmm you
can see the potions at the bottom how
many times can you use the potions I
think you get two jumps and five freezes
five freezes oh you only use one per
turn so you can't use up you can use one
potion or the other once you're out
you're out only one potion per turn and
you you can't
so no yeah you can play a potion and
then move
um
but uh yeah only one potion per turn
are you able
and and let me make sure I State this
clearly
are you able to jump
to a place that would create a check but
it doesn't count as a check or you just
can't even do that you can jump to a
place that would even create a check
make
you just can't if if the queen is
attacking the king
you can't say I'm jumping over this and
you're in check but
there was a position like this where you
chose to jump over the pawn and the
queen went there and it was Checkmate
because the Queen's protected because
the Queen's protected by the bishop ah
so
oh we're in a match here here we go
we're going through a few different how
long does the jump stay active for one
move just during your turn or is it
still active during your yeah once you
jump that's it and the piece stays there
because you jumped so like if your queen
what the heck no way he's popping off
what happened I'm sorry to interrupt
Ed to move before it popped off are you
on the queen oh he missed it look this
is awesome so he chose to jump over his
Pawn on H2 and his Rook on H1 took the
queen oh so he jumped over yes because
the queen was out there
right away
so that's a really good lesson there
let's switch over to Gotham chess I
don't want to miss that match if it's
live and what'd you say
yep there's like 10 you could have
watched like 10 times this year wearing
that
get in the game I see blitzstream
challenge you Levy
you got to play like way more
conservative like you cannot push your
queen up there early watch everything
it's not it's like everything can be
guarded and you still can get taken I'm
standing up for this one you can't go
for some cheesy Checkmate like in two or
three because the enemy pieces can jump
over and they can once you land there if
they if they check you you could just
freeze the piece and lock it down for a
while right yeah you can freeze a piece
that is actively checking you to get out
of check or to make another move which
is actually really interesting he looks
if he's allowed to stand up am I allowed
to stand up can we just
when you stand up you're gonna look like
you're sitting down five three ass
I also would like and now I'm out of
frame that's why I asked permission
because I was gonna piss them off yeah
here we go no you're yelling into it
there we go all right see he's not he's
he's fine he's five three in real life
he's not that much taller he's on he's
like 13 Apple box they're so much taller
than you look I'll go into your frames
okay stand up straight you're on your
tippy toes always a complaint he's
always okay
all right here we go so look at this C6
stop Bishop B5 Levy is really good at
highlighting so he's a great person for
us to follow if we want to learn the
game you know obviously he's going to
tell us what he's thinking so you really
he like gotta move the pawns carefully
yeah in places for you to jump this
would be a very unorthodox opening if
jumps didn't exist is that fair to say
yes 100 yep
so he's playing very defensive here this
is like how I play in 30 second chest
when I'm trying to cheese a win yeah
you're just trying to flag him he pinged
that he wants to move his Queen to be
able to jump over to grab that Bishop
very nice very nice and he highlighted
it
so this is an immediate threat and so
blitzstream should notice this probably
move the bishop back one maybe a Fisher
Bishop there it's a great move back up
the bishop okay protecting it is good
too
um
what's funny about players of this level
though you made a great call to cover
this game is because they're not going
to waste their spells they're not going
to use them superficially and they're
going to try to build them up almost
similar to clash Eric we're like they're
gonna try to combine some freezes and
jumps and a couple moves in a row to
just end the game I need you to explain
the freeze because I don't get it well
they're gonna freeze by yeah wait for
them to show it but when they use it
you you can freeze depending on the area
either uh a 4x4 or a nine by nine area
and no peace in that area can move for
that turn including your own pieces so
you can freeze your own pieces from
making a move which is actually
something I learned in real time today I
was like oh I messed myself up you set
it up to freeze their piece and yeah
freeze your own with it yeah so you can
you when you freeze an area everything
is Frozen They're basically playing
x-ray chess like like the pawns don't
matter in a way yeah and so every piece
needs to be defended and so I think the
other games aren't that's why I don't
care to watch them too much it's because
it's mostly blunder City people are just
not protecting pieces yeah uh which is
funny and we saw sapnap capture on that
failure
so like you couldn't jump over the pawn
and grab the Rook because it defended
two ways yeah and now you need to
protect your queen
it seems like the queen is the most
dangerous piece here
and you can't jump to capture the King
right I don't think so bro you run to be
here
Levy just highlighted it and caused me
doubt I'm gonna ask in real time well
maybe he was just trying to make some of
the Dead Knight couldn't move he's
trying to pin the night yeah possible
and then they Castle to get out of it
either way yeah the castle comes out so
it doesn't matter we're getting
real-time confirmation
yeah I'll also get uh real-time
confirmation because I feel like I feel
like I feel like because
I'm right you can I just confirmed it
Noah buckerman in chat just confirmed it
thank you Noah you and Noah a live
confirmation so you could use a jump to
pop over and trade Queens but that'd be
kind of silly
and so the response from Levy here
should probably be to defend this queen
oh goes for the jump which seems like a
waste that makes sense by the way that
it because that's why you only have two
of them instead of five because the jump
is super op I didn't realize how how
strong it was and that makes me feel
like an ass for all the games I played
today where I was potentially gonna yeah
so now Levy used a jump just to do a a
trade that was pretty negligible for the
position yeah that's kind of weird it
was kind of weird you got his opponent's
Queen off the board too so it's yeah
it's kind of okay but his opponent still
has two jumps yeah yeah that's fair
that's a good call yeah
um
so you do that now if white wants he
could jump that pawn and then stop the
ability of a castle
yeah will he do it Levy's wondering if
he will he's highlighting it wouldn't be
the worst move
Queens are off the board so I think not
castling's not too scary oh it happens
there's the jump
let me also talking about areas that can
be frozen
we haven't seen a freeze yet so this
Rook could jump and capture the king
yeah well if the yeah if the e-file
opens up couldn't you have done it last
oh no yeah
but at one point we might see an
interesting freeze check where like the
White Knight pops into the center like
D5 and or like if you play D5 the White
Knight can take it and freeze all those
pawns so is he gonna do that right okay
he doesn't do it that's interesting
because these guys are better than this
than I am they've been playing more more
spell chess than
me there must be some
counter to that I might say that they
and I don't mean to hurt you could be
better at chess than you uh well whoa
okay that's a little far
we're gonna find out this year we're
gonna Levy and I are gonna be playing in
the same tournament you can watch it
spell freeze tournament those features
Championship just for IMS and streamers
and streamers that's the sick invite
that I got oh I didn't freaking guess
okay yeah um I would dust okay this is
huge though because I need blitzstream
to win and I'm looking at the clock and
I'm feeling better and better about my
chances right now love you with 45
seconds can make a lot of things happen
including life it's true including
create life I don't know where you're
going with that he can move this Pawn up
because if the pawn is ever kicked out
does Gotham still have another jump yes
he does he's gonna both have one jump
and they have not used their freezes
what are they going for so what he could
have done is he could have Frozen all of
those King's pawns and then try to push
his Pawn right
first freeze he can't get away how does
that work now yeah what does that do
wait is that check wait Levy asks if
it's Checkmate because he froze and then
went for a check no no no because
because uh Kevin can counter freeze he
throws his own Knights so he can't move
his Knight no no but he could freeze the
area so the next move Levy still can't
take the king see counter freeze a
freeze let's go
I see a freezing I cannot freeze yeah I
like that Levy could do another freeze
dude it's gonna freeze off we could ever
have a full house a freeze off
dance off
[Laughter]
okay so now he's back in check oh and
now he wins the the yeah my God this is
so yeah it's awesome it's awesome that
was hype if chess wasn't complicated
enough already yeah this is this is
people love this man
spell chest for the win that's fun he's
leaving oh he can't actually take the
Knight because you could jump take with
the right yeah yeah and let me down down
to 10 seconds by the way they have an
increment though everyone so they're
getting I think two seconds added back
to their clock with every move so just
FYI he's setting himself up for uh a
jump take with the bishop
if the Knight moves you could jump over
the pawn and just take the king
so that this is a king the king can't
move you're right but there's a there's
a rook or not a bishop uh defending that
pawn as well yeah but this is a huge
moment he just allowed Knight C6 check
okay I don't want to do with that wow
so he can just
oh he can take one time
he has to act fast he can take with the
Knight and after the bishop takes oh
he's moving his King out of the way I
think that's a good call Levy's running
out of time
jump captures
but he has to make a move
oh this is night four seconds to four
seconds now Blitz your master move let's
go
oh it's just no no more time to think
this is just he's gonna get himself
checkmated dude just two seconds
just freeze and go freeze and go make
them think with a freeze I do think
you're dropping a good reason to be
smart he froze him yeah yeah yeah
he's gonna get him
great call by the way because I I do
think like a freeze yeah it's like it's
basically flagging yeah
freeze is probably just trying to Target
the piece that they'd like to move yeah
because the phrase doesn't replace your
move it's in addition to your move right
all right seems like we have some other
games on the board still so let's take a
look at them congratulations Gotham
chess for taking that one down that was
wild yep team King on the rise we have
another result that just popped up a
couple here uh let's take a look at I
don't know the game with two freezes
producers you pick surprises we got a
double freeze action over there between
sir tax do they play at two games
oh it's two games is it that makes me
even each player will play two games
let's go Blitz stream this is your
chance I don't know if that's right
actually it says uh on on this sheet it
says four games each what are they
playing oh my God there's a lot of
freaking chests for the win that's great
I'm okay with it though this is fun I
like this yeah double freeze you can't
move that you can't move that it's
frozen stop trying to move it he froze
his own pieces that's the problem
he froze his own pieces all right this
match is between sir tag
as you can say it's not the highest
balding use of freezing yes I don't
think we need to watch this match
because
no offensive sir tag they're burning
lots of phrases they're they're mostly
trying to figure out what they can and
can't move by guessing and checking so
let's swap over
perhaps a match-up of of high-level
chess skill can we take a look at
uh maybe Anna krambling versus Ray
Enigma
and a Kremlin versus Ray Enigma let's
take a look
oh they're deep in a game here
wait
commanding is playing virtual
uh that's a different period than we
thought yeah
crambling versus virtual I find it
should be a better pairing oh okay that
that's gonna throw it away hold on does
he have to move the pawn up
well he froze his own queen as well but
does that freeze wear off okay he
counter freezes because the freeze lasts
and then when it gets back to your turn
you can move yeah she did the exact
thing that Levy did earlier she just
moved instead of jumping the pawn and
taking the king okay then the second
time she did the second time she did it
it's so funny to see somebody capture a
king it feels so good yeah why can't we
just capture things yes she she baited
him by leaving that uh wreck open as
well let's go back to Levy let's go back
to Levy that was a great game I'm hoping
they have another good one that's so
much more to watch that's it that's
difficult
if we want to see blitzstream's view we
can do that but maybe see the same or
Levy all good but this is great
I like I like watching Levy yep a lot of
people watch Gotham chess it's kind of
good I'll watch Gotham chess
you go down that Gotham chest algo rep
Rabbit Hole where suddenly his videos
are fed to you no matter where you are
uh yeah and he'll give me Recaps Magnus
Carlson
with a triumphant Victory you know
speaks like he's a an announcer of sorts
yeah
okay we are in it
last time Levy won with time this time
let's see if they're able to use their
jumps a bit more effectively because he
basically uses jumps just to do even
trades
yeah both players were super cautious
with the Spells
and so far they haven't used many of
their spells I think I see both jumps
maybe all five freezes my eyes are a
little rough do you guys see five next
to that freeze sign I don't yeah it's
all five look at that my eyes aren't too
bad huh your eyes are not too bad sir
not yet old man I should use a jump on
one of those Knights moving that'd be
really useful it's Pawn structures for
Hogs they got the hog pieces on there
that's that's not a typical night right
there so what would be the hog pieces
what do you want like they get to move
like three times in a row Hogs jump
walls in Clash of Clans yeah so like you
got you got hog nights you know like
water nights all right yeah I like these
uh this chest thing is he trapped
uh yeah he is the queen is trapped but
he can freeze he can take the Knight and
then free wait what yeah why can't he
freeze the defender and then take the
bishop
you can
you could he could drop a freeze
although it's funny because black just
jumped his own Pawn to do this which is
a very risky jump because the queen
actually isn't trapped it could also go
to F4 for one more Square
the other Bishop yeah yeah the other
Bishop comes out the queen continues to
get attacked
all right I got it
what do you got freeze the night
yeah after the bishop frees up high
Bingo Bango
in fact you could do a three by three
freeze
to freeze the pawn in the night on F6
and then catch it the other night right
what he needs to do is freeze the timer
right now because he's only got 30
seconds true all right so now maybe you
could freeze a three by three on the E6
Square after the bishop comes out and
then you could capture
yeah they're they're playing so
conservative with their spell like I
feel worried about their freezing the
freeze here's a freeze he's gonna do it
you can't do it on that square though
he's gonna freeze his own Queen
but it'll last long enough that he can
move the clean out after he comes out of
it but it'll stop The Rook from moving
right now or the not the bishop I guess
this wasn't stupid
if he drops a freeze lower why would he
have because he didn't need to freeze
his own squares right so well what we
could see here is potentially a counter
freeze there
and lock the queen into place there so
the bishop will get her that's what I'm
wondering is is like what happens if
Bliss stream counter freezes right now
do we just keep running out of freezes
and because if they're in chain freezes
yeah that's what happens Libby has to do
everything he can to keep his Queen so I
think that was that was a mistake to do
that oh he's checking the king okay
he's threatening mate well he can take
the game right there if he if they don't
double up the defense or move the king
so maybe this is how you gain back Tempo
on the freezes is by what's funny is
well he can't take the queen right now
Kevin Kevin can freeze the bishop on A4
and then take the queen if he wants but
uh
but Levy was threatening the King right
there with a jump over the pawn Levy
brings up a great point which is hey the
guy that was attacking my queen
is
attacked twice
are you not allowed to play Independence
right now
yeah it looks like the Spells almost go
on like a cooldown after you cast it
but like time's really low wow well I
just saw the time oh we're gonna have a
sweat match yeah yeah I'm back though
two seconds back Levy won the last time
they were in a Time scramble like this
so I don't know if this bodes well for
Mr blitzstream he brought up a great
Point too that he can jump and capture
oh Queen captures though
oh look at that okay okay okay jump it
jump it jump it jump it no if you don't
have the bishop to take it the bishop
could take it backwards so
that was a good call oh
keeping the Queens on the board time is
sweaty
you're moving fast though these guys are
these guys are Pros yeah and they're
gaining a little bit of time back with
every move oh that was super nice two
pieces actually run defended by jumps
yeah Levy didn't see that
but he still has both of his jumps by
the way
you should probably start using them
yeah that's huge
oh
scary scary I think this is also we saw
the tried and true bring out a freeze
it's Wayne Fern up like this over here
like you could really catch somebody off
guard with uh with a jump like they're
just going to
play off their Instinct stuff uh after
all the practice they may not be able to
see uh jump lining up they could jump
capture they could jump after the queen
right now oh we missed it Kevin missed
it there it is that's huge mistake yeah
they're getting so much time back right
now
he could jump capture again if he wanted
he missed it he could have jumped after
yeah could have done it black could have
jumped captions no no black is outer
jumps oh no sorry yeah I love you right
now there's a hanging oh yeah yeah Levy
can good call look at that Ludwig and
Levy bang I got a brain for this game
give me a tournament he's getting so
excited he got them yeah
it's so funny to see somebody resign in
a spell chess game okay by the way
confirmed yeah they didn't do that
because you can't play two freezes in a
row there's a cooldown for a church that
makes sense you can't just build okay
that's confirmed let's take a look at
Alexandra botez who's in a game right
now
against Rey Enigma now who on paper is a
higher rated player do you know
they've they've used a lot of freezes
already I feel like freezes like almost
have to be played with a counter freeze
and so like if it does have a cool down
then I feel like it's you're playing
chicken the whole time there yeah
freezes like whoever does it first it's
just gonna the other team just needs to
respond with the counterfeit makes sense
and so Alexander just went for like a
YOLO risk to capture the queen
or excuse me to capture the king
but no it's a smart move is a double
attack right she's threading both check
and the queen it's a double attack on
Enigma and by the way she's up a minute
on the clock too so an enigma cannot use
a freeze right now
um because they've used one too recently
or maybe they've used all of them there
goes the queen they've used all of them
they both use all of their freezes
are you sure yeah I can't know the
refresh you know I think I think it
takes a few okay okay yeah yeah I think
it got it the cooldown ends it comes
back and lies back up
I was involved in early ideation stages
and I got out of I don't know so I don't
want to hear this like you should know
the rules Danny all right I don't know
I don't know all the rules you know what
dogs are coming back for that
we talked about your feet by the way
all right
still many jumps on the board you can't
jump a pawn can you
yeah you can
why could you jump a pawn to like rank
up
I think if you were on your initial move
you could probably jump it to move to
forward but I think outside of that
would be yeah there's no like super
power Pawn charge like hog power pawns
would be interesting you just charge up
the board
does a jumped piece have to capture I
guess is what I'm asking
doubt it there's a jumped piece hanging
capture I think it's the movement
freedom I don't think you have to
capture right like let's just say The
Rook on h8 moves yeah can that pawn like
did it make it disappear could have
could that pawn jump to h a promote to a
queen check the king no no because the
pawn can't legally move that far in one
move so it it's still the legal move for
the pawn I see what you're saying okay
so now we're gonna see if they do the
counter phrase here because he saw her
use the freeze there so if they counter
freeze and lock up or Pawn Yeah I don't
think a counterpiece here is good I
think it was really smart by Alexandra
because look at one look at the time and
the threat was that Knight was going to
move to F3 and check the king and that
was going to be devastating so that move
that move with the pawn is is huge and
there's no really like useful counter
freeze because she was really only doing
it for defensive reasons but it was but
it was key but they could yeah I guess
if they do freeze counter freeze the
pawn to stop it from taking the night
then he could well then yeah
right because it still depends on where
they put the freeze like it's only
covering the white pieces then then I
would be able to be moved off to the
right
yeah but still like black can't move the
Knight next turn
what is Ray doing he's about to lose on
time I was waffling yeah this is a round
of time oh interesting we've got two
minutes you can take your time
that was that was see he did freeze it
right there that's what I said what he
did was
prevented that night in front of the
king that hog night from moving which
would have opened up the queen so she
can't move it yeah you can't do it
but she can run with the King she can
run with the King out which is probably
the best thing to do
is just yeah she's about to do it okay I
would I would go to D2 I would have ran
the other way that puts your King right
in danger
I don't know but there's not a lot of
things that can move very far on that
side of the board right now it's all
nights yeah is it really that much
danger right now
interesting yeah a little tree off of
the corner so many pawns on the right
side that's absurd
yeah a lot of Pawns only seven seconds
for enigma there's no way she loses this
I feel like I'm getting better at
Chester's watching them you're getting
better at a weird version of chess for
sure
that's probably not gonna help me unless
I go play it yeah in which case I'll be
right
she needs to move fast I think I feel
like I'd enjoy this kind of chest though
yeah she's kind of no way this is good
yeah I like chess power-ups is this bait
is that night bait
yeah you need to be careful because if
she does that he can free he could jump
with the Rook
IE so she could freeze yeah and then
capture that Knight right
I didn't realize you could overlap the
outside of the board there she freeze
her own damn night she she Mouse slipped
the freezes she just screamed God damn
it I read her lips she she Mouse slipped
and then she moved her own night into
the freeze but the freeze will be gone
it doesn't really affect her but she
just though she definitely swagged it
right there in class we call that grass
in the freeze
just kind of throw it off on the edge of
the board during accident yeah
that was tough that was hard to watch
that was a wasted freeze what so
normally if you're just like clicking on
the board there when you're nobody if
you click freeze and you don't want to
do it there's a cancel button below the
board and she tried to click cancel and
instead she froze the corner of the
board she could just capture that night
that's a hanging night
oh okay yay that's a huge problem
um okay she should still win this
yeah that was the right move
just take things now yeah
yup catcher yep okay
okay
I don't think I'm going to protect the
night and then he'll come back up she
has to counter freezer I don't think she
has a toy freezes now she should move
the queen up one square but that also
threatens Chuck I think Queen E4
threading Checkmate on the E5 was also
good but that's gonna be enough oh okay
all right I heard that oh that was time
I didn't realize time was so low yeah
time was very low for rain the whole
time she had a she was in a good spot
anyways all right let's go to sapnap
where are we at can we get a Barb versus
King update I'm freaking out over here
and it's already hot in here like I've
been emotions are running hot I get it
you fear me you fear what I'll do to
chess.com I'm gonna change her to
ludwig.com you're freaking out he looks
really relaxing I'm also I'm getting rid
of him croissant I'm getting rid of
onpassan the French have had it too good
for too long
we're getting rid of it oh man
uh yeah I am nervous I would like to
understand where we sit just so I really
know we'll get there we'll get there
you're breathing heavy drink of water
you're breathing heavy again more Waters
uh let's take a look at
let's take a look at virtual who's in a
game right now okay virtual is playing
cramling
virtual is in a tough spot
but maybe it has a better grasp on this
game mode than we're giving them credit
is that his King in the center of the
board indeed maybe he doesn't have a
better grass
you call that uh developing the king is
that is that is that a game you develop
all your pieces that's correct there not
the king not the king all the pieces all
the pills always develop you missed the
step ABD always be developing always be
developing the ABCs of Chess always be
closing always be developing okay
um
his chat isn't even talking you know
that the virtual world
they have to turn to emote only chat
they're not even chatting yeah I don't
know why you turn it in team mode only
like chat would have a good suggestion
but this game chat would only be a net
negative all right
he could
it seems like the best pieces to jump
are Rooks so getting Rooks into to
useful positions and open files is
pretty hype
agreed town
okay
yeah
okay he just froze the king counter
freeze to save Checkmate makes sense
can't move the king though
I gotta Dodge he can wait until the
freeze wears off then he can move though
yeah he could just develop here maybe
you know just move he could move the
bishop
so yeah move the bishop move the bishop
over to
what is that A6
A3 I don't know how the the letters work
no I like I like that move right there
he has a good Pawn yeah go threaten the
Knight so if he does take your knight
no he can't take the Knight what do you
do here because oh he's trying to make
the night move
he has to move the king back no matter
yeah you're right you're right he's
gotta avoid check
that's weird because it's like not
telling you we're in check right now
because it's still frozen
oh that was a good call defends the pawn
yeah this is getting spicy oh you're
really getting involved here virtual
some would argue a little too involved
there with that King
the King on the on the fourth rank not
ideal
bad I was gonna say I think Bishop E3 is
just Checkmate by the way yeah she sees
it the king's just trapped but he got
freeze and not only freezes on cooldown
right now yeah freeze on cooldown can he
jump down I was sitting there like I
think there's a Checkmate in one
and the King jump down like just one
square I don't think you can I don't
think you can do anything illegally
still except he's no you're done you're
toast that is so funny like it's just
well he can jump to get into position
right talk about the most still you
can't make a move that is illegal for
the peace
so a king jumping over the pawn doesn't
allow it you can't do anything it's all
shouldn't it say game over he can't find
the move there he's running out of time
he's gonna lose on time regardless even
if he even if there is a move he can't
find it I don't know what the move was
either somewhere apparently virtual
putting his hands in the air what was
the move I don't know the move is there
analysis for this there's no engine for
this yet there's no let's take a look at
Levy we got our final game coming up
right now it looked like sir cat just
took one Gotham chess and his match
versus
Blitz stream it's a sweaty one
or they both got they both have seems
relatively even seems like they've
learned
they have jumps on the board yeah Levy
just said what kind of game is this it's
a rook ending
okay
yeah he just he's like what are we doing
here this is just a rook ending
I don't know what we're doing here
either
chess and Clash had a baby
cute
the kids have said Ludwig that
it's a dub collab what does that mean
what do you think they do I think it's a
w collab W Club I think both these games
have collectively given teachers around
the country nightmares so how much time
it has taken away from class time yeah
I think Clash
oh look at this that's very nice this
March
clash and chests are probably top two in
the past like 10 years you just missed
Force mate he had rookie one king H2 G3
King H3 Brook H1 made oh my God how'd he
missed though so obviously yeah so I saw
that from everyone was talking about it
he's muted for a while but freaking out
because that was my guy's chance he just
misforced mate hmm
oh
oh I'm still holding a jumper he's
threatening okay like he's defending
through the jump like the they're
actually got a pretty good grasp on this
I feel like they should be using their
freezes and stuff yeah yeah they're not
using them at all you're freezing the
counter freeze are they even on freezes
right now but they're playing like I
feel like uh these guys just get into
their into their mode when they get into
the game like this and it's all just
like muscle memory yeah I actually think
the same thing it's actually a problem
for them yeah it's throwing them off
their groove if they try to find ways to
use it while they have the timer
countdown hey this shed is yelling at
him to use a single spell ever please
God please you should freeze that whole
area freeze that whole area right now
yeah you should have froze the king at
least and make them
he could have stopped promotion
I guess can you freeze a queen and
capture the
if I'm crying yeah look at that oh yeah
but counter freeze another King's stuck
and he can't get away right
uh yeah and then you move the Rook over
to defend no you're gonna take it with
the queen because the freeze will be
gone yep
God damn
God it was clever but it obviously my
brain isn't built for chess and it's
doubly not built for watching two grand
Masters play this game all right we got
a freshie a hole we can't watch these
two it's too much of a blowout let's get
a um what else we got we got what do we
got we got the Alexander's who's a mod
playing Amon Hamilton versus Maestro
luisan I believe can we check out him on
Hamilton
Amman Hamilton he won one not too long
ago
Maestro Maestro my Maestro luisan is uh
It's Tricky he's tricky AF as they say
the kids say that say it again
looking for the match that means as
funky
they are wrapped that's what I thought
who won uh I'm on it wasn't
4-0 I'm on Hamilton okay
so a good result for team I mean I
didn't want to say it but you did I'm
just checking my checks here everyone's
like not too worried anymore about the
old uh
well I'm not sure I'm not even sure
who's ahead right now yeah good check no
no cramling is ahead against virtual
wait no I'm on Hamilton is ahead I think
I think that alone is an 8-0 swing
uh and then Levy's going kind of even
always every win counted individually or
is yeah I think I think every win counts
every win counts oh geez I don't think
it's like hey did I beat the player in
more the most wins wins The Challenge
the most wins wins yeah nice paraphrase
uh yeah I feel like every time you use
freeze you have to counter freeze like
it has to offset each other
cool activate the Knight why not why not
activate the night
I believe this might be one of our last
games here this is our penultimate
challenge by the way before we enter the
final challenge of the day
the final challenge of course is The
Clash of Clans raid challenge where they
have 20 minutes plus however much extra
time they've earned throughout these six
challenges uh to get as many crowns or I
should say stars as possible I think if
uh Team Barbarian can pull off a win in
this round here like it's gonna be a
shootout into the into the Clash of
Clans yeah because I feel like I feel
like team King is is better at Clans
Clash of Clans what do you think I mean
if I'm looking at their lineup but
you're the expert I mean who's got the
edge in regards to our Clash experts in
The Clash of Clans I feel like at this
point that since we already know what
trophy range that they're gonna be
playing in when they get to Clash of
Clans and they're really they're really
in the low end I think we're gonna see
triples like racket in like crazy uh as
long as they bring an army right yeah
but we saw him on Hamilton put up a
donut
we saw him put up a zero star that's
what I mean that was that was the one
that didn't have an army and by the way
popping off because she says she has
forced mate she has pushed her Queen
there oh piece by the way can only jump
over one other piece
so she can jump over this Pawn right now
to capture the king and you can't
capture the king in this mode
uh virtual could block with the the
bishop but then that would mean there's
only one piece between her dark squared
bishop and the king and she would use
the bishop to capture the king and he's
already used all the freezes that's what
she was showing in the replay that's why
the freezing right yes and the freeze
cooldown is currently going he has four
freezes left but you can't do it yeah
yeah you could do
uh
gulagoon he probably needed to do some
sort of jump to distract but that's
that's a quick one easy that's a quick
one it's getting getting out of hand
here for team barbs well do we have any
matches going do we have a score to take
a look at I'm not feeling great about my
team's odds virtual
emotional all the games have finished
that was our final game so
early on
team King one two challenges they're up
four minutes it was a tie they're up
five minutes to team barbarians one
minute then team barbarians sweeped the
next two games it was five minutes to
five minutes this was our final game
let's see the results
and let's see which team team king or
team Barbarian
won the most wait quick math 7 11 16 10
16. it's time it's a time no
oh
[Music]
green before I'd like to take a look at
what happens for breakdown yeah I'd like
to see the score breakdown as well okay
we're going right through it well this
is yeah this is the results so it means
that there's no clear Advantage going
into the final challenge okay they both
get six additional minutes can we go one
previous
shout out to the team who made these
pairings by the way right right this has
turned out to be quite the uh quite the
Clash yeah the chess clash
I wasn't involved in that whoever made
these pairings did did some good game
theory look I can totally believe it was
scripted because I'm pretty sure I saw
nobody get zero and I know two people
got zero but it doesn't matter what
matters is the final challenge which is
The Clash of Clans raid challenge again
the four excuse me the six previous
Challengers were all for an advantage
for this one uh we're about to jump into
it
chess players I'll let you handle it
Eric I don't need to get through I'll
let you please explain to the people at
home what we're about is everybody
playing or is it just the is it just the
chess players uh chess player oh you're
right test players of H2O take control
coach by The Clash player so it's only
the chess players that dude are giving
and getting advice there from there so
it's basically like the previous game
mode yeah the only difference yeah is
that they have limited attacks and
they're on a timer to get as many done
as they can so oh no this is where it's
gonna get tricky here because if you're
able to get a if you're able to get a
three star and I saw a lot of them
breaking out Electric Dragons which is
going to be very very smart for this I
feel like that's what they should stick
with but if uh it and that assumes that
they're they know on my team
if somebody doesn't get a three stars
they get a three star they're going to
clear the base really really quick and
they can move on a nice attack and
they're not allowed to exit out of the
tax early if they start to like burn a
lot of time with the only small amount
of troops like if they know they already
got a two star but they're not gonna
triple and they got some random stray
troop just off doing whatever on
something that's meaningless then they
could end up bringing a lot of their
clock very very quickly during this
phase so I think doing some using heavy
hitting troops that will just either
take the base or die straight out is
gonna be the best play to go here
because you need you need everything to
either three star or just get out of the
way so you can go to the next one
otherwise you're gonna burn a ton of
clock here and it's basically going to
be a 26 minute timer and then it's going
to wrap up it's going to determine this
is going to be this is going to be I
hope we have like a active star tracker
as we go through this 100 will have that
guaranteed I can see production
literally saying I promise we have the
writing it on a screen we promise we
will have this for you if we don't we
will venmo you Ludwig 100 each easy that
was star tracker I saw it I saw it
written there I saw it right there so
that's that's the basic premise of it
I'm now I'm a little
the to me this feels almost random
because a lot of the latter mode is who
you run into and the timer already
started by the way we are in our 26
minute countdown started okay you want
to say random I mean it who you run into
in the latter Can Depend it can be you
know because they're not attacking yet
the time is ticking do they know now
experienced uh players are gonna be able
to like what is this Army here like this
is going to be terrible uh he needs to
change that Gotham you need to you need
to fix yourself there where's all
embarrassed for you we think your army
sucks
yes I mean he did get triples with it
but it's gonna be a slower perhaps it's
an impersonation of the country he's in
he didn't bring a good army he brought a
white flag
sorry production sorry
people of France and all that uh oh man
okay Domingo just got a little high five
from someone in the room there I'm just
I'm people watching he's in okay okay oh
he's off
were they skipping
he's he's prep I see uh Gotham pressing
next there go into a base that he can uh
be able to fight wait so he's basically
cycling through bases trying to find
something that you can triple easier I
guess I didn't know you were there
allowed to decide how does he know oh
it's probably his his brain but if
you're sitting there I guess if they are
allowed to Cycles or bases to find one
that they can uh maybe take out a little
bit faster and easier than their burning
cloth there while continuing to search
when they could be rocking the stars and
just go just go as soon as you see an
easy one like you're saying it's been
almost two minutes he hasn't attacked
one base yet yeah like he's burning a
lot of clock right now and this is
basically I mean at the end of the day
we can't blame Gotham okay so if you
just put like all of his troops in a
pile on most of these bases have you
seen right now he could triple him he
feels very very unconfident what he can
do here well it's not him right he's in
a call with his Pro his teammate is
telling him to skip this is teammate his
teammate to be fair sapnap oh this looks
free this looks free it does take it
just send it they should just be sending
everything that they got because send it
here they don't have a limit on the
number of attacks they can do they
should just be safe every single send it
click all the troops click them all
click them all click all the buttons let
the buttons go Burr
yep
and nice air remember the last time we
used the air Grand Warden yeah his his
uh Clash coach is barely able to give
him the proper advice here so I feel
like that's I feel like we can uh blame
sapnap for this one I don't think it's
uh his fault small improvements here
and so he's sweeping through the base
again you get up to three stars he
already got two stars you get one star
when you clear the town hall but all the
troops that went around the far far left
side there that are just wasting a lot
of time just circling around in a giant
pack they're like they're like like if
you're trying to go for Speed then you
want to be attacking multiple things at
once but if everything's in a pile then
they're all going at the same building
and then the next building and there's
way too much Firepower concentrated in
one spot where he should be surprised
he's still gonna triple but he wasted a
lot of time in the process so he got us
one star for getting the town hall
second star for destroying 50 of the
base and the third star comes if he
destroys a hundred percent of the base
there it is that's a three star for
Gotham chest and it only took four
minutes and 20 seconds is that good
that's bad because it's three minutes
normally he had equally uh difficult
bases or equally easy bases to go after
earlier on but so now he what he needs
to do is quickly train up the next Army
here and he needs to get the other one
trading in advance there but I guess he
can just uh let's take at somebody from
Team Barbarian let's take a look
at Anna kramling and see how she's doing
how she's handling this time crunch
so you can see that she's she's tackling
she's doing the same strategy because
there's almost like a like a pattern
recognition even that I can tell well
it's like oh that's a formation that
many people are using is that standard
so no one of the biggest things they
should be looking at here is the town
hall level so the the big white building
in the middle there the town hall so
it's intimidating if we see a white one
or a blue one they should be attacking
every single is that a level 14. that's
a level 11 and he's she has level 14 uh
equivalent truth buddy let's let's say
troops go Hog Wild that's a White Tower
right there if you're attacking two Town
Hall levels below yourself and they
don't have Max defenses on top of that
even if they do have Max defenses you
should be able to drop all your troops
in a pile and just three star it
like that that's that should be a really
really easy pickup right there and so
like I I I'm pretty sure that she'll
triple this even if she made every
mistake in the world do you think I
would score a triple double on a
basketball court if everyone on the
basketball court was a 10 year old
no I do I do I believe you would can we
go to Crocs
I'm watching you I beat Gotham chess in
Crocs once this looks like 100 let's
take a look at Ray Enigma on my team I
was dogging him I was saying Ray Enigma
is a reason I'm gonna lose reading but
won't get a single star let's let's take
a look to see if that's actually true
and see his point of view he's being
coached by the great zokas
so you said it's Joker
um that sounds like a character from
Lord of the Rings or something this
close Soka Rey Enigma is there great
yeah not doing a lot here not doing
anything not even in a is he trying to
upgrade his uh defenses right now that's
not really gonna help him what are we
doing here Ray
you got this right what are you doing
right take your time Ray don't you want
to bot on chess.com take your time right
we're all right
um what's funny is well so a lot of the
Clash Royale content creators that are
that's a tier 13 Tower
that's that's a town hall 10 or that's
Town 12 but it's got defenses right now
that are like town hall eight and nine
levels so like that should be just drop
all your troops along in a line there
and you should be able to Triple that
without any Easy Pickins yeah that's a
really really easy one as well them's
Easy Pickins that's what they should be
doing they should be going after the
easy ones but they're skipping a lot of
bases it would be equally easy and I'm
noticing that they they don't understand
I think they they definitely don't
understand the strength of the what they
have on offense and so they're being
excessively picky where they just sent
it on most of these bases they're
skipping I think they'd be getting a lot
Stars a lot more stars a lot quicker
they're greedy is what you're saying
yeah a little bit I mean
I skip a lot when I uh when I'm
searching for loot but there's no excuse
because you're not looking for Louie you
just need Stars Eric do you think human
greed is inevitable
what are your thoughts on that
um yeah yeah I think so I think so we
live in a capitalist Society so like uh
I'm gonna go get that back
well let's take a switch over to Ray
Enigma see how he he's faring he he was
buffing up his bases a bit earlier
hopefully he's actually in a game now
because my team needs points and they
need them now can we get a star update
at some point I'd love a star update
yeah I'm a big I'm a big star update
kind of guy I got a star up day for you
yeah I see two stars on the screen
oh on the right hand side hey it's me
new Big Shot he's still quieted by that
uh well
you did say I would not get a triple
double against 10 year olds and I won't
forget that sometimes it's hard to just
know the truth you know the uh Crocs
notwithstanding I I think you're under
as a guy who has more 10 year olds than
anyone should ever have you know how
many 10 year olds I've I've had four
kids so I've had I've had more tenure
that's four too many ways
the point is 10 year olds 10 year olds
are not good at defending physical
Sports I'm not sure why they aren't
stopping to rate the game
stopping to what rate the game when
little oh yeah pops up it's kind of
disrespectful yeah exactly you know the
Clash of Clans they're having fun he's
making this come to life wait he's
upgrading his stuff now he's training
right now he's just training but if he
on the last tab at the top there there's
a quick train so you can just retrain
the last Army that you used and so they
should be retraining the same Army if
they're going to use the same one over
and over they could just hit quick train
gem it and get a next one there so like
when you're do when you're when you're
working oh actually this is
they're throwing real hard here Amon
Hamilton might be the single reason why
you lose what are they doing I know I am
so frustrated I'm on well okay here's
the thing Amon Hamilton should be in a
call with sir tag right can we listen in
is there an audio feed we can receive I
want to hear
sir tag should be able to give him the
advice
yeah
dude maybe not those are Expos this
guy's this guy's not uh people are
saying you can get one star you get 50
they're saying these are the same people
that said my troops looked ready
I I have faith in them dude
get one star and end immediately when do
you have 50. okay end immediately and
immediately they said I don't think they
know
so that you can keep your stuff
so the thing about surrendering is like
I'm actually not sure you're allowed to
well Oman is correct you're right it's
forbidden to leave a fight once it
started oh oh really okay thank you for
actually reading the rules oh yeah yeah
yeah I got you hey how do you think
they've gotten this far without knowing
that rule and also not having half of
the Warriors you should all they have is
the heroes which are by default you end
up getting them and as long as he's
jamming them for the next fight there
because uh obviously they're not gonna
heal fast enough what do you I'm sorry
gem in them so when the heroes after
they get through the first two fights
they have to they have to start healing
up and so if you want to go attack again
immediately either you have to pop a
magic item to make so you can play for
an hour straight which I still wouldn't
heal them quite fast enough there but if
they want to do back-to-back attacks
they have to gem their armies a live
score update incoming team King 2018
Barbarian 27 it is a race to the bottom
between these two but we are halfway
through our time right now who do you
want to take a look at Danny I'll let
you pick super close keys to the kingdom
I gotta see what uh let's see what botes
is doing let's get let's get Alexandra
up there see if she can get the team at
dub there we go I like that Alexandra
bote yes destroyed half the base this
seems to be a well-coordinated attack am
I right
no but
no it's doing fine it's doing fine she's
doing she's doing much better and one of
the key things one of the key points of
Victory there is she's bringing an
actual Army she's actually she's
actually filling her Army Camps there
which uh obviously gonna have a big
impact they're they're swagging a whole
a whole Duo there like that's really
Gonna Hurt the overall score
all right there's a triple for botez all
right you saw a tripping from your team
I want to see a triple from my team show
me Ray Enigma yes sir Ray Enigma the
inevitable is what they call them the
inevitable and that is a free base
everybody who's using the electro
dragons right now we're playing it right
here because the electric dragons are
one of the fastest uh fastest troops in
the game and they're very powerful and
they don't really require a lot of uh a
skill to be able to take out a bases
lower level than yourself so like if
you're attacking on an even playing
field if you're like in the war mode of
the game then the Electric Dragons might
be a little bit difficult to get a
triple but if you're attacking
somebody's lower level than you the
drugs are very very very good and they
can do a lot of work very very fast so
they're the ideal troop for this mode
Pro tip to my team before this started
well like first of all let's take a look
at them on Hamilton because you really
think that's the tip that they needed
was what troopy he needed something to
help him
my God this is sapnap he is helping
coach Gotham chess and Gotham chess is
for the most part crushing well
this will do this will still get the
triple because the bases are so weak
compared to their offenses and so
they're still able to get the triples
here even with uh with not an ideal Army
here so like he he's he's making it work
he's he's he brought the wrong tool but
it's still getting the job done if
you're making an ideal Army would I be
in it
um yeah yeah yeah I don't know what trip
would you be I would be a uh 10 cost
commander and I wouldn't fight but I
would lead others
you literally just described the grand
Ward and he's the most powerful troop in
the game wow he boosts every troop
around him you don't have to suck up to
him just because I'm just saying I
didn't I didn't I didn't actually look
that up I just that's what was it it's
25 space though it's pretty close those
but there's there's you're there's
actually a new troupe that just came to
the game called The Apprentice Warden
and he's closer to what you would be I
think because it doesn't do a lot but he
boosts everybody around that would be
The Apprentice that would be the master
yeah yeah that's a good call can respect
that all right Anna this is good for the
win rounding out the 100 this strategy
seems to be ubiquitous across the chess
players to scroll through until they
find a town hall that's weak enough to
take for the plundering we go back to
Sir tag I want to see if they're
actually bringing in an army yet they
change their game plan yet sir tag
spectating
look at this they're actually training
some e-drags now they got them thank you
someone gave them a tip uh here's the
thing so I shouldn't need a tip late to
the game though a little late uh well I
don't know if we have a score update we
can find out if we're too late to the
game because last we checked that team
King was only up one and they're on uh
Barbarian and there were only one point
behind so if they are actually
contributing now then they can actually
take the lead man that would feel good I
just heard from production they said
it's close trust me okay all right it's
close see how we just dropped 11 and a
half minutes here this is some very
elite what that is not close at all I
lied I didn't hear production say that I
made it up what is going on with you
barbarians
uh that's that's bad for you that's
horrible I'm I'm wondering
do I even keep you on right fire me I'm
just it's like and more to have a Steve
job situation right right take over and
then you're trying to like seed power
back for me just get you you know no
often it's better just to start clean
you know I'll ship you to Macau with
200k
all right I'm gonna sit back in this
chair stop with this standing desk thing
and I'm gonna try to
I'm gonna try to send my team some
energy that must have been a scoring
error and I'm not calling into Integrity
anything I'm saying I think in the
timing of it it showed right after the
Kings had just won a bunch and didn't
show The Barbarians to rephrase we were
saying Denny's saying stop the count
right right stop the count until we get
a recount okay this is against it you
know I'd like to get a recount
um
you want to recount them storming the
town halls
just want to make well we're we don't
definitely don't want to go
is this an easy take here what town hall
level is this this is 11 but it's got
defenses that are like town hall seven
or eight level right now together they
just rush over town hall building up but
they left everything else behind so
highly not recommended but everybody can
play their own way and it's just gonna
put you at a very very big deficit I'm
not gonna cap Eric every time you talk
you say I wouldn't do what this person's
doing it's uh it's embarrassing all this
group of what I would call in your eyes
failures who's doing the best I would
say who shines maybe a little less dully
than the rest I think uh I'd say Anna
kremling is doing best
out of everybody there so let's watch
Anna Kremlin let's go to Kremlin I like
that she's on team barbs I need to I
need a barbell full Victory you need
Amon Hamilton to rewind time hey they're
they're doing stuff now they're finally
putting some triples on the board there
so they're making some progress but I
wonder if they said their team back too
far there
but it is nice to see everybody move in
a little bit faster now the pace is
definitely picked up all across the
board yeah we see our wide shot here
this is all of our players here's Blitz
stream
in a level 11 town hall base is that
right that's a town hall 12 is the blue
one how can you tell the other one was
blue the just the main building in the
middle of the base there that the E
direction we're on the same page where
it was the exact same building the blue
one is Town Hall 12. the white one is
Town 11. no no there was a blue one that
you said was Town Hall 11. blood and I
have you on camera saying the last blue
Tower was 11. we got you all right we
got you sucker I'm denying it even if
it's on camera I'm denying it all the
way through deny deny deny I respect it
blitzstream will have neck pain for
years but at least he will also have
three stars yeah that's not a
comfortable that's not a position you
want to be in
so I I get a tablet you got to get a
little man you gotta get those little
tripod things to put them in so you
don't have to like lean all the way down
the table is that what they do I have to
get like a tripod on the desk right
there hey or you can just pay from your
phone they can hold it up but it's hard
to play on a tablet that's laying flat
because then you do kind of crank down
over it
you know retweet plus one let's take a
look at Anna Kremlin
the greatest gamer here
uh she gonna miss that town hall she's
gonna kill a lot of time right here but
no the no the queen already used our
ability it's a level 12 Town Hall that
is yeah that is the blue one is 12. yes
you okay no she's probably still gonna
come back later but okay
um
she does a triple in a minute 30.
so she's not getting tripled though
because she well she's using up a lot of
time on this one here because she's
gonna have to go back to the town hall
so there's going to be a lot of uh time
to transition back out to that area
there but I think she does have enough
troops to actually take it now right
behind the town hall let's see right
above it there is a single Inferno which
can burn through heavy troops there
really really quickly just like in The
Clash Royale you had The Inferno dragon
that once it locks on it builds up its
beam until it uh is able to take its
Target very quickly so that thing could
uh you just saw just took that stone
Slammer out and it could stop her from
getting the town hall here which
definitely cost her a lot of time I
think she does overwhelm it but I think
she well she just burned a lot of clock
yeah this actually is insanely slow I
called it I was hoping she'd be done in
a minute or 30. she's she's chewed
through over two minutes here yeah yeah
it's not great it's not great for team
barbs
but she's gonna get it yeah it looks
like she'll get it yep okay she got it
and now she's making a mistake as well
so we saw earlier we saw that uh Amman
was using the air warden for a ground
attack now she's making a mistake and
she's using a Ground grand warden for an
air attack he's the he's the only hero
that toggles to Air and ground mode it's
just so you need to have him match what
you're using enemy in the air you're in
the air enemy on the ground you're on
the ground makes sense
to me it makes him very vulnerable
because if you're if all of your army is
air and he's on the ground then the
ground only targeting troops attack him
directly where normally he follows the
troops and boosts them just like uh
ludwood if he was uh if he was a troop
right I would do that you would I would
do that I would actually be an air
Warden wow yeah virtual and OJ seem to
be a pretty good team it would be a
space Warden wow they're just killing it
I would send out drones to hunt down
certain areas
and I would justify it in post no can we
take a look at Amman Hamilton because he
can he contribute he might have fully
swung from being a
what I would call bad player to maybe
one of the better players okay he's
about to get three stars in a minute
here we go like 12 seconds
you're seeing like a a character Arc
from the beginning to the end of the
yeah where he's just kind of learning as
he goes you know there you go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go I love it
I learned how to trade in a bit faster
good let's go oh that didn't feel good
production that didn't feel good
down 27 that is tough
this is one of those moments where you
just hope that everybody on team King
just gets their internet disconnected
that's so mean of you to say
you know what I hope everyone on team
Barbarian has a great time maybe maybe
somebody just hasn't delivered their
account yet and they're just waiting so
they've been ready
to jump in 30 stars real quick but
they've revealed like one of their cards
and you're like oh you had two pair and
then it's like Full House again
someone's gonna do that
I think
you lost I I think we're watching the
slow demise and what I'm what I'm also
thinking of is what I'm gonna do though
can I just pick what to do for April
Fool's Day that sounds like a really
good compromise
well no and I still on the website I
mean yeah I mean you know hind shakes
I'm gonna have to look into that
um
salary of a million dollars a year
oh my gosh
I cannot believe this happened I also
feel robbed because in the middle day
as the potential future owner of
chess.com I have my first decree
I would like the GM badge on all my
accounts
does the CCL get a get a salary
I sure hope so you I I you are you
already said it if you're taking over
the the website then I gotta I gotta be
CCL the uh yeah
sure I mean certainly a sea level
employee gets something but you know we
got to think about our problems you know
yeah we gotta cut where we can right am
I getting laid off before I'm tired
don't consider it a layoff it's a new
opportunity oh I'm gonna open a new door
for you I also by the way have a strict
no sharing money policy right don't tell
anyone how much you made which in this
case is nothing at all but don't tell
anyone
um if anyone get Circle back to that
because you kind of dodged that can I be
GM
you can be GM and I would also like to
choose what happens today for Fool's Day
and then I will I'll see back to you
control the website
okay so what are the stakes right now
right now I would like the title of GM
Grand Master Okay I would also like to
control what happens on April Fool's Day
okay
and in return I will give you your
website okay which I've rightfully
earned in a handshake deal which is
binding in the court of law it was on
camera too it was on camera all right
yep
oh wait should I do something else on a
million dollars
just keep that in there real quick
20 bucks okay all right okay hell yeah
here we go here we go good deal good
deal I'll split that 20 with you
nineteen one
for your contribution over there my CCL
deserves it thank you I appreciate it oh
man well this didn't go well
well you know what did go well the day
today yeah we're in we're in beautiful
party okay I woke up I went I went to I
went to the shop de Mars
I had the cappuccino got to enjoy the
beautiful city here and then I got to
experience The Wonder of clash which I
was not as familiar with and also the
Wonder of Chess categories I was not
familiar with yeah
and then the combination of the two the
bastard child yeah which was a beautiful
thing the dub collab as the kids say it
was a
child you don't want to say it but you
want to do something wholesome here now
all these uh now all these guys are
gonna be hooked so next time we uh do
something like this you know like
they're gonna all gonna be Pros by the
time we get there you know I did that I
ruined the top Grand Masters career by
turning him into Clash Royale that'll
happen addict yeah that person's name
his name is
Fabiano caruana is good at chess still
what if they he is you know he just
suddenly Rose to the top there they just
like got so hooked he's like that same
competitive he's now also like top
couple thousand in the world at Clash
Royale well Clash of Clans and Clash
Royale have a massive Esports scene as
well so like this is this is very low
level play with these guys are doing but
I think these guys channeled do you
think there's more money in Clash
Esports or Chessy Sports it's it's I
think it's definitely Chelsea Sports
really yeah but it's so top-heavy
it is but Clash is really top-heavy yeah
he and I were going over the ecosystem
today and no no offense to clash but I
think there's definitely I've learned
there is more money in chess Esports
professional chess I think I think um
it's funny because chess lacks
distribution in terms of viewership in
terms of like there are growth
opportunities still but I'm learning the
top chess players are actually doing
pretty well and they should be happy
if chest has pretty big Esports Clash
has pretty big esport then the
combination game should it be the
biggest
and because of that my first decree
it's a 100 million dollars
smell chess clash Championship three
seconds
and it is over we're done baby the chess
The Clash
the whole final challenge the whole nine
yards the the kitten caboodle is done
oh my gosh my fantasy drops in nine
minutes but more importantly we now have
to determine who the winner was we're
going to tabulate points
everybody already knows the team King
won because Danny seam sucks
just get it over with I'm although is
there something in the chest no
whatever's in the chest is yours ah it's
yours whatever's in there is no not
yours not not yours I'll just I'll pick
it up for it it's Danny's whatever's in
that chest is yours that's your
consolation prize
oh
you got all the money in there they
don't want us to open it all right
forget it does it open
I don't I don't think it opens no it
does open
what's in there
oh that's embarrassing
oh there is stuff in there it's an
ancient scroll we probably shouldn't
show this on camera
what are you guys doing hiding stuff
like that I didn't expect there
what is it I don't know that if I'm
allowed to what is it hey we're already
this far we can do if we want
it's the streamer Lord Zary Lord sorry
he left it here now it's yours maybe he
didn't want it enough for this
Shenanigans we have to congratulate our
winners today team King which includes
names like virtual Gotham chests Luis
Rey Enigma The Clash side OJ
sapnap christanini zocus they are our
eight winners and for that they each
will get their own bot on chess.com with
a final score of 137 to 106. it was not
close
not only do they get their own bot which
will be available uh on 9 15 which is
soon what a fast turnaround y'all are
gonna have to do you know we're gonna
bust them out they also will get five
Royal passes on Clash uh Royale and
Clash of Clans per Talent 100 euros
worth of gems per Talent uh and they'll
probably give them to their community so
if you guys want free gems just go to
one of those streamers streams and be
like I actually watch you the whole time
I love you so much by the way what are
you gonna do with your gems and maybe
there's a chance you'll get it yeah put
it in their comment section just blow it
up and wait more importantly if we go
back to the star count that we had right
there for every Star one thousand
dollars were donated to healthy gamer
Foundation up to 50 000. we blew that
out the water
they only needed 50 stars we had
243 combined which means fifty thousand
dollars goes to healthy gamer Foundation
which is really cool so special thanks
to supercell and chess.com for making
that happen uh big thanks to everyone
who competed the production who put this
on uh as they say in France
thank you very much uh thank you to
everyone who watched at home uh and and
that's that's it from us thank you to
Danny Eric for commentating any final
thoughts
uh GG guys that was that was good I
wanna I wanna see
I wanna I kind of want to go play some
spell chess like that was actually
actually like a lot of fun I want to
puzzle rush and get over 20 and shut
your your big head up
you're gonna be in charge of that soon
you can even change the algorithm if you
want but uh I think I'm excited for the
ray Enigma bot like what is that bot
gonna say
given that he doesn't talk just dot it's
like dots just three dots every single
line he talks he just doesn't yeah I
guess he talks you just talk okay yeah
words hell no face though well either
way that's something you'll have to
figure out godspeed on the next week
eight bots in one week gosh dang it are
we okay hey that's what we do here chess
you go crazy anyway that is GM Ludwig
that is
fide Master Danny what are what are you
it's now I'm nothing I'm oh come on no
God come on you have the company back
internet Master yeah thank you thank you
what the heck that's crazy that's really
I mean that's it's not a gym uh and of
course Eric yeah that's uh official
title you gotta like send me like a
plaque or something like that yeah we'll
work on it anybody put on my desk yeah
okay well I'm off to do a fantasy
football draft thank you all for
watching have a good one see you later
goodbye see you later everybody you did
that thing that they do where like they
they tear it up and throw it like you're
a professional at this hey I got a job
for a reason
[Music]
it's gonna cut
thank you
[Music]
foreign